Five,
four,
three,
two.
Hello,
Sam Harris.
Hey Man.
Good to see you.
Happy to be here.
It's great.
I listened to your podcast with Jack.
Let's just get right into the jump in the Jack stuff because I listened to your
podcast with Jack and I found something very when I did my podcast with Jack.
First of all was not anticipating the blowback that I received.
It was stunning.
Uh,
but um,
he,
what,
what I thought was I was just going to have a conversation with this guy.
Be Fun.
See what it's like to run this gigantic network that helps people communicate.
You'll be okay.
Jimmy helps people communicate and distribute information worldwide.
What is it like to start something like that up and have it become what it is
like how have you managed to try to keep up with it and one of the headaches
been and apparently people online,
particularly the people that want to comment about this,
all they wanted to know about with censorship and that was an issue with me.
There was a question with me,
but it became a far,
was a far bigger question for people online.
They felt like that I tossed him softball questions and that I didn't press him
and then I listened to your podcast and one thing about Jack is very smart guy,
very nice guy,
buddy talks in a very slow and methodical way and when you ask him a question,
he takes these routes and if you don't want to jump in and press them like
you're in this weird situation where he's not totally answering your question,
but he's talking about the same subject that you talked to.
Like for instance,
you brought up Louis Farrakhan,
like how's Louis Farrakhan and good standing on the platform and someone like,
you know,
fill in the blank,
Milo Yiannopoulos or Laura loomer,
whoever it was,
they get kicked off.
He never got to that.
He went around and around and around with you.
And um,
he recognized this after the podcast,
I received a lot of blowback.
He received a lot of blowback.
So I contacted him and he said he'd be more than happy to come back on again and
address all these things.
And I said,
okay,
what I'd like to do is address specific instances of people being censored.
And he said,
okay,
what I'll do is I'll bring in someone from the company that's in charge of that
stuff.
Right?
So I'm starting to put together a picture of what it's like to be a ceo of
something as big and he's also a ceo of square.
He's runs the cash app,
there's a lot of stuff going on there,
right?
So He's obviously busy.
How much day to day involvement does he actually have and who gets censored and
why they get censored and how much is he willing to share about that.
So we're gonna find out in the next follow up podcast.
But I got accused of everything from being a shill to being a cook to being a.
and there's also an issue that you've managed to avoid wisely.
So you'll have advertising the cash apps and advertiser on my podcast.
So because the cash apps and advertiser on my podcast man had you by the throat.
Exactly.
Anything couldn't ask all those great questions that were queued up.
The reality is,
those are the questions I would've asked.
Now that's hard to say
because no one's gonna believe it,
but those are the questions that were asked and I tried not to be too
confrontational with a guest,
but in hindsight I probably could have pressed more particularly on people like
Kathy Griffin calling for doxing for the,
the kid with the Maggot hat on with the native American.
There was quite a few,
but I noticed that.
Well,
what was your experience like with it?
Yeah,
so it's interesting.
[inaudible] you and I have a,
we had different interviews because there were time differently.
I mean,
it's an interesting topic because this opens the door to all the ways in which
our podcasts are different.
I mean,
they use stream live.
I sit on my podcast for at least a week in Jack's case was like two weeks before
I released it,
so I did my interview with him before this flurry of interviews with him came
out.
I mean there's a rolling stone interview.
There was a,
uh,
I think only,
I think maybe a Huffington post interview would come out,
but basically there was nothing out there,
so I had no real examples of how he dealt with these questions or how he talked.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
I mean slow talking.
It's not a problem for me because I'm one of the great slow talker.
So,
so we're,
we're in a groove there.
Um,
but he,
um,
I,
I didn't know what his boiler plate was and how he would,
he would answer any of these questions.
And your podcast came out before mine did,
but mine was,
mine was before the Covington Highschool Catholic.
Oh,
circus happened,
right.
So the real missed opportunity for me was just a sheer matter of timing because
the commitment thing put such a fine point on everything that's wrong with
twitter and the way journalism interacts with it.
Right.
And it was,
it just,
you know,
I think it was a farhad manjoo wrote an op Ed in the New York Times saying
twitter is destroyed journalism and,
and,
and it was not a crazy op ed.
In fact,
uh,
after the Covington thing and the whole unit,
and then Kathy Griffin would've been the perfect example to talk about it.
Like why is she still on if she's calling for the Doxing,
right?
Yeah.
But you know,
I,
I think I had a substantially similar interview with him that you did,
uh,
because he's,
there's two things.
One is he's great at sort of pure wedding around the,
the,
the sharp point of question of what is the policy and why or why are you
applying it and in this seemingly disparate way.
Uh,
and it seems to skew politically in one direction all the time.
Right.
But I think you also,
you know,
I did,
and I think you did naturally,
we cut him some slack in that he's the CEO of these two corporations.
He can't be expected to actually know what happened in every one of these
microcases.
Like,
I think I brought up the case of,
I think her name is Megan Murphy.
I hadn't even heard of her,
but she's a lesbian woman that she was a feminist who said sort of the wrong
thing in the transgender space.
She said something like,
men are not women and she got banned and or to know,
I think it was temporary,
but you know,
so I raised it and you know,
he,
he obviously can't know exactly what happened in that case or at least it would
be surprising to me if he knew.
So the fact that he doesn't have his finger on each one of these cases and what
the,
what the rationale was,
and he has this sort of generic answer that what you're seeing,
you know,
in public is not necessarily what we're seeing.
In fact,
in virtually every actionable case is not what we're seeing in private with
respect to how these people are all opening,
opening multiple accounts and doing seemingly nefarious stuff behind the scenes.
Now,
whether that is true,
I don't know,
but I mean I can just say that Jack seemed,
um,
one,
I,
I liked him and he seemed unusually open to talking about anything I wanted to
talk about.
So as I saw one allegation they got a hold of you,
is that,
you know,
you must have been constrained by the topics you couldn't touch in advance.
He must have had some agreement with him in advance,
you know,
it didn't happen with me right now.
I should address that.
There was no,
no discussion whatsoever about what was off limits.
No nothing.
And he asked her.
No.
So in my case,
I tell all my guests and this the difference between use streaming live and,
and me not,
I tell all my guests,
listen,
if at any point in this interview you put your foot in your mouth or I put my
foot in there,
we can edit it,
right?
Like we,
I want you,
I want you to be totally happy with what you say over the next two or three
hours.
Uh,
so if you have to take something again,
take it again and,
you know,
we'll just hide the seams as we go.
Now that virtually never happens.
Right?
And in Jack's case,
there wasn't even a wrinkle like that.
So,
um,
but,
you know,
I,
I just,
you know,
I,
I recognize it's a high wire act for a lot of these people,
especially if someone was running two publicly traded companies.
Right.
And um,
you know,
I also want to invite in Amman,
I said,
I said jacket,
we were DM and on twitter and I said,
listen,
I promise I'm not going to make you smoke a blunt on video that got him.
So I don't know how you got him,
but I didn't try to get them to a local boy.
I didn't even think about it.
Yeah,
we weren't drinking,
we were just talking.
Maybe we'd been better if we were drinking because it did seem very stiff.
I listened to it after the fact and
I mean I get from their anticipation why it would be disappointing.
I just thought it was kind of boring.
I thought my podcast with them just wasn't very good.
I sometimes do too many podcasts and when I sometimes do too many podcasts,
I think I run low on juice and I'm not as a,
I don't know,
I'm not as engaged or I'm not as fired up about it and maybe I just should have.
I've definitely should've prepared more for him,
but I really thought it was just going to be a conversation about what it's like
and I thought that would be really easy to do because it's such a unique
position to be running something like twitter,
but he,
you know,
I don't know if he was evasive in because he didn't know the things or because
he didn't want to talk about the things,
but there was things like he didn't know exactly why Alex Jones was ultimately
banned.
He didn't,
he couldn't recall or didn't know.
Now is that because he couldn't recall it was because he didn't want to talk
about it or is it because he didn't remember it?
I mean,
I don't.
I don't know.
I mean,
you'd have to,
you'd have to be inside his head to get that answer.
Yeah.
I mean,
he,
he's clearly got a,
a very practice line that he uses to answer these questions and because I,
you know,
I know what it's like to have boilerplate had been a book on a book tour and
you're just basically going to ask the same questions again and again and here
he's getting asked fairly pointed questions about where twitter's going and he's
got,
you know,
I don't think this is dishonest,
I just think,
but it has this amazing ability to close the door to further inquiry because he,
he gives you the full mayor Kulpa right upfront.
You ask like,
what's,
what's the situation with,
you know,
the seemingly asymmetrical banding of people.
And he'll say,
you know,
yeah,
we really,
I mean we got to get much better at communicating our process.
We're not nearly transparent enough.
This whole thing is in disarray and my job is to fix it.
Right?
So it's like a global,
you know,
we're fucked up and we're going to get better.
I promise you.
Right.
And there's,
do any good for the people that are already banned.
Right.
But actually,
there's not a lot to get beyond that in an interview,
so it's whether,
you know,
I don't think it's nefarious.
I think it could well be totally honest.
Uh,
but it does have,
this is a fact of you just keep reaching a certain kind of brick wall,
but you know,
it was going to be there.
Yeah,
that's a,
I felt that too.
And I didn't,
didn't really navigate that very well and that was a big part of the blow back.
But then the blow back was accentuated when they found out that he sponsors me
because the cash APP is one of his businesses and sponsors the podcast.
Yeah.
Well I had a very similar result and I don't have that problem so that I don't
think that diagnosis your situation at all.
But it's very interesting that the difference between these business,
that business models under which we run our podcasts and I'm just the different
mean just every choice you make and how to produce a podcast.
I essentially have made the opposite one,
you know,
like streaming live like this ms dot the fact that you're.
So this is just all very interesting to me because I'm a kind of a reluctant
student of digital media now because I've just kind of stumbled into this wild
west that,
you know,
you in large part have invented,
right?
I mean this podcasting space was nothing.
And now we've got spotify,
you know,
buying up and it says like a land grab for audio.
Yeah.
That we were talking about that before the podcast.
They just purchased some company.
Was it,
what is it called for some godly amount of money,
like $200,000,000.
Not going to spend $500 this year or something.
And so it's this,
we're all just making this up and you know,
I'm making and you know,
I've just released a meditation APP which is a different business model still as
a.
Now I have these kind of two digital businesses happening in my life and it's
um,
it's just very interesting.
The decisions you make are a force to make and the consequences of it.
And so like the fact that we're having this conversation live,
you don't even have to think about whether you're going to edit this right,
because it's to be streaming live and you know,
we're going to,
when we're done,
we're going to turn off the mics and walk out of here and your job is done with
my podcast.
That's not the workflow at all.
And I,
so I,
I totally envy this,
this approach that you have,
but for a variety of reasons,
I feel like I can't take it in,
in my life.
And so it's,
it's,
uh,
but it is very different.
Dictates many choices,
you know,
down the line,
which I'm,
uh,
I mean there's,
there's a positive,
a negative,
but it's,
you know,
the positive is what you hear is what we got and we're done after we turn these
mics off.
And that's,
and that's not,
that's not how I podcast.
There's also the visual element of it.
And the visual element of it in initially was almost like a side effect.
I mean,
we,
we first started it out visually,
but then when it started going to itunes,
the itunes aspect of it became the focus,
the audio version of it rather became the focus,
but then we decided to stream on youtube and put it up on youtube,
but it was totally not profitable.
It was just for,
for a goof like,
oh,
we'll have the video up.
Why not some people like video.
It was one of those things.
But then you realize ultimately that youtube becomes a viable source of revenue
and then it's also the way a lot of people like to watch it,
you know,
and they also like to watch it because they can comment under it.
So that was the other thing that came out of the Jack podcast.
We got into a controversy about comments and about how comments are deleted or
how they're shown and hidden and what happens because people were accusing Jamie
of deleting all the derogatory comments that we don't touch any.
We don't,
we don't delete any of them.
We don't do anything to them.
We just leave them up there and it's mostly a cesspool.
But I mean,
even even on a good podcasts,
there's a lot of crazy shit that happens on these things,
but from what we think,
and Jamie correct me if I'm wrong,
you think that what's going on is that people are marketing other people's posts
as spam.
Yeah.
There's that.
And then brandon also has a theory that a lot of all right people are targeted
by the algorithm that youtube uses.
Like in one case there was a guy who had a pepe the frog Avatar,
and he said like his.
His comment immediately went to spam and that the other thing is that the
comments are curated depending upon who is watching it and what account it'll
be,
there'll be different sort of,
yeah,
that they'll propagate different comments to the top.
It's not a this.
You can actually change it if you,
if you prefer to see the most new comment from your own personal youtube when
you're watching you,
you as a viewer or a user of Youtube have to make that actual.
Yeah.
So that,
that conspiracy theory just heightened the whole thing.
Right.
Okay.
Now they're deleting negative comments like,
look,
I don't like doing bad podcast,
but I will be the first one to tell you when I think a podcast sucked.
That podcast was definitely disappointing.
It wasn't good.
Mine wasn't good.
It was like I said,
when I listened to it,
I was like,
Kinda,
this is kind of boring.
Just wasn't,
wasn't juicy.
There was nothing.
He didn't get a flow.
It wasn't like he and I were just shooting the shit.
Having a good
time to take that one decision.
Say you have decided to make video,
a main component of this podcast are still probably a small percentage of your
actual listens you're out anymore.
When it was not anymore.
It's gotten to.
It's almost 50 slash 50 because they're closing in on the used to be like 90
slash 10,
right?
Yeah.
So I have it.
I don't have a video component and so I just put audio on Youtube,
but I put absolutely no energy into youtube.
Uh,
I mean that may one day change,
but because I don't,
I don't care what's happening on Youtube.
Right?
So I never see the comments and whenever I look it is,
as you say,
assessable,
it's insane.
I mean youtube is just skews massively,
right?
It skews just massively male and it's probably skews very young too.
So you have it just like millennial alt right.
Craziness,
right?
It's like,
like as I say,
these sentences,
your youtube pages just blowing up with hate for me.
You've got a bunch of millennials with a thumbs up.
Their ass is just wind,
you know,
the older people too.
Well,
yeah.
But I mean it's got to be younger than most of of where.
Well first of all I'm not even seen most common threads they could possibly
respond to anything I put out there now.
Right.
So I got to,
I don't even look at my app mentions for the most part.
I spend maybe five minutes a day looking at it.
That's healthy was coming back to me.
But.
And you were actually helpful and reformatted my brain on that,
on that topic.
But um,
so because I don't see any of that stuff,
I mean maybe I'm getting a lot of pain for my Dorsey interview but I don't even
know about it.
Right.
And so I'm not having,
um,
I don't feel like I have to course correct in response to anything now and in
large measure it is a consequence of justice decision that,
you know,
I inadvertently made that I'm just,
I don't have a video component to my podcast at the moment.
And so I'm not,
I'm not spectating on,
you know,
the feedback on Youtube.
Well the feedback thing is interesting because we were just talking about this
before the show that with feedback and comments on Youtube essentially anyone
can comment and if you don't go banning people from the channel,
which we don't do,
it's not what we wouldn't do if someone was totally a piece of shit but we
don't.
So you essentially have this open forum,
so it's like almost like a message board where people could just sort of comment
and it's unlike twitter in that regard because twitter just,
you know,
you get abusive and Shitty on twitter,
they just get rid of you.
If you get abusive and Shitty on instagram or on facebook,
facebook,
they'll just get rid of you.
But if you're on youtube and you're in those comments,
you could kind of get away with more.
So I would imagine that people that don't appreciate censorship and want to just
just fucking spew out whatever's on their mind,
that would be the place that they would go.
Especially if it's the same.
Essentially.
The only thing different,
and this is the thing where it got confusing with the youtube people versus the
audio people with the audio people.
It's very obvious that the cash app as a sponsor,
because it's we say it,
this podcast is brought to you by the cash app.
Whereas in Youtube they like,
ah,
they're hiding the fact that the cash apps,
a sponsor.
We talked about it during the podcast itself,
but we don't put the ads on Youtube.
We,
there's ads that youtube puts on,
but we put the ads on like after the show is over I'll read the ads and we'll
insert those into the audio and that will go up to itunes and rss feeds and all
that stuff.
So the stuff that's on youtube,
it's abbreviated in the sense that especially the live one doesn't have
anything.
So like this has zero ads and then the ones that will be posted on youtube
later,
a little bit of Youtube ads.
Right.
So that's why this.
So there was a couple of conspiracy theories in that regard.
There's also apparently an emerging conspiracy theory about that.
Jack was trying to pump up bitcoin because they have some sort of a bitcoin
deal.
Have you heard this one?
I read that,
but from what I saw it's not higher than it was at any point.
It's still right around $3,500.
So if there was a pump and dump scheme of some sort then like it should be like
provable on a blockchain I guess.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I don't understand that,
but is there any other component to it?
I don't know.
I don't know where that was coming from.
This don't even know what did it all he said was that will the cash app sells
bitcoins.
We talked about
coin.
You can buy and sell bitcoin through the cash app,
I should say.
I think he said something about blockchain technology,
rendering everything permanent online and that was.
That was something different though.
Yeah,
but that,
that I think that's in regard to comments into anything.
Blog posts,
blockchain is essentially going to have everything that's online forever,
but there's so many fucking conspiracy theories about all this stuff.
It's,
it's fascinating.
And as you know,
we were talking about earlier with your,
the way you do yours,
you used to use patrion and now you use your own website after the Sargon of a
cod incident,
which,
you know,
beliefs stepped back away from
patrion now or not.
So no blade depending on what you think of Oregon to pick out.
Yeah.
Well it's not even that.
It's.
Yeah.
Well,
there's so many misconceptions about what happened there and I tried to clear
them up on my podcast,
but yeah,
there's an interesting implication to not taking ads.
I mean,
I,
I think what's happening,
and this is much bigger than even podcasting,
I think
I'd be interested to know what you feel about this.
You have,
you are the quintessence of the successful ad model in,
in podcasting,
right?
It's like this is you.
It's working fantastically well for you.
And for people like Tim Ferriss and probably Mark Marin.
I mean there's this,
there's some kind of like a winner take all thing happening in this space where
ads are working great and I am a really also a highly successful example of the
support model.
It's like the pbs model or the NPR model and what's weird is that I can't,
like we,
you know,
you and I are both surrounded by people who have podcasts,
want to have podcasts and are asking us for advice about how to succeed and how
to monetize.
And like I'm not even in a place where I can recommend my model to anyone else.
Right?
Because it's,
it's a very,
it's very hit or miss.
I mean I had just happened to have developed an audience that will support my
work and you had developed that audience previously,
ironically enough on youtube,
there's a lot of youtube debates and random people calling people putting my
content on their youtube channels,
but they're mostly debates,
right?
Yeah.
And as a,
you know,
as an author,
but it was just a podcast grew and I had this sort of for forest choice where am
I going to go the,
the,
the ad route or,
or not.
And I found that I may have two things to,
to say,
you know,
fairly strongly against ads,
but really only one of them applies to me and I don't think it applies to you or
tim or,
or anyone else.
Um,
I just felt personally I couldn't use ads because of sort of what my platform is
and the kinds of topics I'm engaging and it just didn't work.
I mean there was nothing high brow enough where I felt like my credibility
wasn't getting subtly undermine.
Bye Bye.
Shilling for it.
I mean,
it could be something that I just legit loved and it could've been the Oxford
English dictionary,
you know,
like you guys is the best engineer in the world.
You guys should use it.
I still couldn't do it and I tried it with the only thing I took on as a sponsor
was audible.
And I did that for some weeks and then it just,
you know,
I love audible but,
but it,
it just felt wrong.
And so I decided to just experiment with a different business model and it's
working for me,
but it's,
I don't think it can work for most people and I view that as a problem.
And uh,
and,
and the thing that I think is interesting is that this is much bigger than
podcasts.
And so you have,
like you have facebook on the one hand,
which is just a,
a totally free platform.
Where were the users don't even realize that they're not the customers there at
the actual product,
right?
They use as the users are having their attention sold to advertisers and it's
this enormous business.
And on the other end of the digital spectrum,
you have Netflix,
which is just a stark paywall,
right?
And there's no way in but to pay the subscription and you know,
that's,
and Netflix could run ads and get more money if they wanted to,
but they're not,
they're not doing that and presumably won't do that.
And I'm hoping just generally speaking that the digital future looks much more
like Netflix and much less like facebook.
And because I see what ads has ads have done is they've anchored everyone to the
illusion of free.
Everyone expects their digital content for free except in places like Netflix.
Right?
So like if when you release a comedy special,
when you release your next hour and you sell it to Netflix,
I would imagine there are very few people in,
in your fan base who are thinking,
well fuck Joe Rogan,
why didn't he just put that out on Youtube?
Right?
Why is this on Netflix?
They,
they sort of understand that this piece of content is,
belongs on that shelf and that if they want it,
they have to subscribe to Netflix.
Whereas if you did something slightly different,
but functionally the same,
if you put it on Vimeo and charge people $5 or whatever in a vimeo on demand,
um,
you,
I think you'd get a lot more pain,
right?
You know,
people would say,
well fuck you,
you greedy bastard like you've,
you're already doing great.
Just release your stuff.
Right?
Yeah.
And I view that as a problem as like,
it's like a psychological problem.
People have been anchored to the ad subsidized model more or less everywhere and
they expect everything for free.
And in my world I'm trying to just continually brook that expectation and push
people into a different sense of you get what you pay for and,
and the so that the hybrid model I've created for myself is I'm putting more
stuff behind a paywall,
right?
I mean,
so that this is not just pure sponsorship of otherwise free content,
but I'm,
I'm very personally,
I'm very uncomfortable with the idea that if someone actually can't afford it,
they can't get access to my content.
So I just tell people,
if you really can't afford the stuff behind the pay wall or you really can't
afford my meditation APP,
just send us an email and we'll give it to you for free.
Right.
So I've heard that.
I was like,
this guy's crazy.
I mean it's actually,
it's actually in the pricing,
in the APP store for my meditation APP.
It's like there's the pricing and then below that there's,
if you can't afford this,
you know,
here's the,
here's the email address.
I think that's fantastic.
And so that's,
yeah,
I'm splitting it that way,
but I'm raising prices.
So it's like,
it's like,
because I think everything is too cheap in the,
in the digital space I think.
I think we're anchored to.
I mean there are people who will spend $5 a day on a cup of coffee everyday for
the rest of their lives and he had a few told them this podcast or this app that
they,
that they say is incredibly valuable to them is going to cost them $5 a month.
They,
they feel raped.
Right.
You know,
so it's,
you know,
and I completely understand it because I know what it's like to hit a pay wall
and think I can't get my credit card out again.
I'm not going to pay for this.
I'm going to find this information somewhere else.
So we've all been anchored to this thing and you know,
something is going to win in the end.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I think at some point,
you know it's going to look much more like Netflix or much more like a facebook
and I'm,
I'm,
you know,
I'm throwing my lot in with the former,
but it really is the wild west.
Well,
the Netflix things different because Netflix has programs that cost a lot of
money to create.
This podcast is very
easy.
You're my friend.
I call you up,
hey,
you want to do a podcast?
You coming over here.
I mean obviously we had to pay for all this equipment,
but other than that it's just bandwidth and rent and all that stuff.
Other than that,
it just goes up.
Whereas you do a comedy special across hundreds of thousands of dollars.
You have to secure a venue,
you have to hire staff.
I mean it's a big deal.
That's an.
That's an easy thing in terms of like bang for their buck,
what Netflix will get out of it.
If you do a television show,
I mean my God,
you,
you need to hire hundreds of people.
There's wardrobe and makeup and set and there's writers and producers and
executives and everybody has to go over the script with a fine tooth comb.
It's incredibly,
incredibly strenuous.
There's a lot going on when you create a television like stranger things or
something like that.
I mean you have so much special effects and so to ask for that for free seems to
be to me seems ridiculous.
Well yeah,
but,
but except I mean,
so I'm kind of split.
Again,
I'm running on two tracks here.
An APP is much more like a television show.
Surprisingly that than it is like a podcast.
But yes,
but even if it's just a podcast,
if you want to build something,
if you want to build a media company like,
like,
like let's say you were,
let's say you were asking for support for this otherwise free pod podcast.
People don't know what your aspirations are.
I mean maybe you want to start a podcast network,
right?
Maybe you have,
you're trying to build a business that is that maybe you have massive payroll
expenses that you,
you know,
so the expectation that the products should always be free closes the door to
any of those aspirations if in fact you have them and you know,
it's like,
um,
I mean it is very interesting psychologically because.
So I,
so I have,
I've created this network of support for my podcast,
but I see people do calculations that they would never do in a more
transactional space that they were just like,
let's say buying my next book.
Right?
So like,
um,
for me offering a free podcast and then saying if you find this valuable,
you can support it,
right?
That,
you know,
from the side of being a creator of that content,
it feels like the most transparent interaction possible because a person can
listen for free for as long as they want to just discover how valuable that is
and then they can support it to the degree that they find it valuable.
Whereas if I'm selling you a book,
you can't even read the book before you before you buy it or you have to make
the decision to buy it.
And I'm trying to convince you to buy it because it took me all this time to
write it.
And,
and uh,
you know,
you're,
it's,
it's transactional.
I'm with,
but with a podcast,
people make calculations that they would never make when they're just figuring
out whether they want to buy something that's like,
like I'll really along the lines of what you just described.
People say,
well,
how much has the podcast costs to produce?
Right?
Like,
like if I knew what you were spending the money on and what it costs you to do
this podcast will then I would support you.
Right?
But they're never saying how much does it cost to write a book and if I knew
what you were going to spend the money on once you,
once you were once,
once I bought this book,
then I would know whether or not I wanted to buy.
They either want the book or you don't.
Right.
So the problem with the support model,
and that's the problem with Patriot and everything else,
is that it engages the,
sort of the philanthropy charity side of the brain,
right?
And people are worried about what you're going to do and how much it,
all costs.
Like how much does it cost?
Right.
Like that.
That's,
that's a question that someone is asking when they're donating.
It wasn't been donating.
And the problem there is they're not understanding,
you know,
just the opportunity costs.
Like I,
you know,
I have to decide how to spend my time,
am I going to spend 90 percent of my time on a podcast will that,
if.
So,
that closes the door to,
to virtually everything else I can do.
Right.
So it's,
you know,
it's,
it has to become a viable business.
And so,
I mean,
I,
I've recognized now that I am,
you know,
to some degree going against the grain of human psychology in asking for support
and now I,
now I feel like I'm going to ask much less,
I'm going to tell people what the business model is and you know,
instilling and remind them of it,
but I'm personally,
I'm going to go more and more in the direction of putting stuff behind a paywall
and if people want it then they can support.
And so it's,
it's kind of sort of Netflix,
the ultimate version of it would be if it were Netflix that would also let you
get it for free if you really couldn't afford it.
I mean that,
that's the guilt free business model that I'm converging on that.
I like it.
I like how you're thinking and I'd like the ethics involved in it and I think
it's a great thing.
And when you set it on your podcast,
I was shocked,
but it makes sense coming from you.
Um,
my thought is I'm in negotiation or in discussions right now,
and I talked to you about this too,
about building an APP and what I want to do with the APP is have a set amount of
money that you pay per month if you want to sign up for the APP and you get the
podcast with no ads,
right?
So you could either get it from itunes or whatever you google play or Google
podcast or you can get it from the APP and if you get it from the APP,
you pay x amount per month and you get the podcast with zero ads and it'll
stream live.
I'm going to figure out how to do both those things.
My thought going into advertising when I,
when I first did the podcast,
I've been doing the podcast now for nine years.
When I first started doing it,
there was no ads for the longest time.
It just costs money.
It costs money to,
for bandwidth,
it costs money to put it.
But I was doing it for fun and I didn't care.
And I had my revenue was coming from other sources.
Um,
a few years ago,
uh,
I decided what I was going to do was,
because I was getting ad,
the first ad request was the facebook was the fleshlight rather,
and you were the first person to request I killed them to not have the
flashlight on your podcast.
The first podcast that we did in Prima Donna
was,
it made sense.
I mean,
they were disgusting adds to.
we would get ridiculous and,
and be really silly and those ads,
it was just the juxtaposition.
I just,
just knowing that the Mike would go hot and then 15 seconds before it would
still be ringing in their ears if you want to jack off with this fantastic
device.
And here's Sam Harris,
neuroscientists,
but moral philosopher,
the fleshlight experience,
some pretty significant positive impact from that.
I mean their business went through the roof because of the podcast.
I mean,
they're really sold a shitload of flashlights where they told me that like some
ungodly number,
like 50 percent of the flashlights they were selling was codeword Rogan.
So I don't want a picture too much.
The armies of people using their product,
you know.
So word got around and then as the podcast space started expanding,
then advertisers,
tentatively we're dipping their toe in my philosophy and it's still holds 2006
or seven or
2012.
The first time I was on here it was 2011.
Wow.
Maybe the end of 2009.
Two thousand 10 was probably on before.
Yeah.
You were probably around 2010 or 11.
There was no other ads other than the fleshlight though with you.
Um,
and then the fleshlight dropped off when we started asking for more money.
They're like,
ah,
I think we hit the point of no return.
But my philosophy getting into advertisement was a,
I'm going to do whatever the fuck I want to do a 100 percent and have no impact
whatsoever on the content of my podcast.
Like whatever advertisers that I choose,
whatever advertisers that
make deals with,
they have to understand that there's no way I'm changing the content of the
podcast and if I lose them I lose them.
I don't care.
And that was the thought process going in.
So I never hit a snag like this cash app,
Jack Dorsey thing before where people think that the reason why I was easy with
him was because of the fact that he sponsors the podcasts.
It's a very obvious
conflict of interest,
but people have to realize that if they churn out off your podcast,
you've got just an endless number of advertisers.
There's waiting lines.
Yeah,
so I mean the cash out logical opponent,
it's just one way of looking at it that they.
They buy a lot of ads.
They do buy a lot of ads.
We do have a good relationship with them,
but I don't need them if they went away.
I have too many ads and that sounds gross to say,
but it is a fact.
I have many more ads than I have spots for ads,
so if they went away would not hurt me at all financially because I put a limit
on how many ads I do podcasts.
I also don't ever interrupt a podcast with an ad.
I don't do that because I don't do that.
That cost me money,
but I just feel like the experience of listening to a podcast unbroken is so
much better than listening to a podcast.
Be Right back with this word from Casper mattresses.
You know,
it just feels gross,
but in the beginning I'm like,
look,
you know where it is.
You can fast forward,
but maybe you're into this stuff.
Maybe you need stamps.com.
It may be whatever the fuck you need.
Those are the ads.
They pay a lot of money.
I'm going to take that money and I'm going to do whatever the fuck I want and if
these guys decide,
oh,
you smoke pot or you're too controversial,
or you talk about this or talk about that,
we're going to drop you.
Okay,
that's my philosophy and I've lost ads.
Have lost sponsors.
Okay,
I don't care,
but if I lost the cash app because it was too high,
hard on Jack Dorsey or if Jack Dorsey comes back and I'm too hard on him in
grilling him about these people that have been censored.
I hope it doesn't,
but I like him.
He's a nice guy.
I want to know what the fuck's going on there.
I,
in fact,
I'm having Tim Pool come on tomorrow.
Tim Pools of investigative journalists,
independent journalist who was used to be with vice and he knows a lot about the
censorship issue with youtube or with a,
with twitter rather.
And he knows about youtube as well,
but uh,
with who is censored and why,
who is removed,
who's been deep platform,
why they'd been diy platform and where the inconsistencies and you know,
where,
why,
why is it skewing so heavily,
right?
Where the people in the right are the ones who were getting banned.
The people on the left are getting away with a lot of crazy shit.
So we're going to,
we're going to get into the weeds with that and if the cash app hears that and
they decided to drop me as a sponsor,
I don't care.
I really don't care.
This is a major source of income for me,
but it's only one source is one of the things that being a standup comedian
working for the UFC and having a podcast and I have a podcast with ads on
youtube.
And and having ads that are on the regular podcast itself,
I'm free in a sense too.
I have plenty of money.
It's not whether or not I'm starving or worry about paying my bills.
I'm free to do whatever I want to do.
Well also actually be clear like I don't think because this can sound totally
sanctimonious and it's not intended that way.
I don't think my scruples around at reading it as on my podcast apply to you or
Tim Ferriss or many other people like tim is the ultimate example.
Tim is somebody who's brand on some level is what I'm going to do is I'm going
to go out there and find the best shit in the world,
the best shirts,
the best workout equipment that is,
and I'm going to tell you about it.
So I want to know what tim has found.
Tim,
if tim is reading an ad for something that is totally brand convergent for him,
and I think you're very much in a similar situation if you're talking about on
it or whatever it is.
It's your own you own part of on it.
I should also be clear that I say no to a lot of ads that I don't want.
Like there was one,
there was a uber for babysitting.
I was like,
get the fuck Outta here.
What are you crazy that got recommended to me by somebody.
But it sounds like it sounds like it sounds like craigslist for babies.
It sounds like a disaster waiting to happen.
There's been a few that I've said no to quite a few.
Some of them that are just boring.
I'm like,
I'm not reading that.
I'm not selling that.
That's stupid.
But also you're a comic
who can send up ads and saw.
I mean I think bill burr does this where you kind of trashes the ad as he's
reading it because he lost naturebox cause he told people to go eat apples.
Really
fucking apple.
So I mean that's totally.
And that's something that's a tool you have in your wheel house that has a
effects down the list.
Like it's one reason why you can stream live without really worrying about it.
And I feel I can't like.
So it's like at the end of the day,
like if things go completely haywire on your podcast,
you can say,
listen,
I'm a fucking comic,
what do I know?
Right.
You like,
you can just,
you can just pull the rip cord and you're fine.
Right?
I can't do that.
Right.
Like you can't say,
I'm a more
time.
Yeah.
So I mean,
I,
I can and there's certain circumstances where I should,
but it's like I,
I should avoid those circumstances.
Yes,
yes.
So,
uh,
you know,
I have to prepare more for podcasts and um,
I feel like I personally,
I mean it's,
it's as much as out of concern for my guests as well.
Like I just,
you know,
this is a high wire act,
but I want to net normally so that people feel free to be totally unguarded
because they know that if we have a spazz attack,
we can,
you know,
uh,
even uttering spazz attack will screw.
So some people's careers.
Right.
We actually had a conversation about a podcast that I talked to you about one of
your podcasts where you said that you actually started it over.
You started.
Let's try this again.
Let's just start from scratch.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean I,
maybe I,
I think it would,
I don't think it would be sport into a sandwich podcasts that was.
But yeah,
so I had a podcast that went completely into the ditch for the first half hour.
I mean,
just brutal.
And I said,
listen,
there's a really,
there's a good conversation for us to have here and now I know how bad this can
go.
All right.
So like now I know just where the track is.
I have to struggle to keep the train on and so we're going to reboot.
We're going to start again and let's see what happens.
And you know,
the podcast was,
was not perfect and I got some criticism for it,
but people didn't understand that we were like,
you know,
we had uh,
we had,
I had,
I had seen the pit of alligators and didn't want to fall in.
Well,
it made more sense though when you told me that because I'm like,
okay,
it was heated before you even got to go because you had already gone through a
half an hour of back and forth.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
I think people need to understand what it's like to do one of these things too
because you know,
you do it so often,
it becomes pretty and you're so good at talking.
You're such a good orator and you're so articulate that it comes off smooth and
easy.
You just having a conversation with someone,
but you're always considering the fact that people are listening to this.
You're always saying,
how do I,
how do I get more out of him or her?
How do I take this and how do I get this person to expand upon this?
How do I,
how do I make this something,
make something out of this?
This is one of the things that I felt with Jack because he was talking in this
way and we're really working hard on fixing all these issues and I'm like,
oh Jesus,
I got to change my gears here and try to figure out because it's almost like
we'd have to restart again.
Every time a question would be answered,
he would stop talking and I'd go,
okay.
The next day.
So long.
You forgot what you asked.
Yeah,
well it's almost like I have to restart the momentum of it,
but.
Well again,
I'm,
I'm totally,
I'm that kind of speaker so you know,
I,
that wasn't a problem and.
But I didn't know what he talked like I'd never heard him talk ever.
So hearing him talk there and talking to them live,
you know,
I mean some people are fucking effortless.
Some people,
like Elan took awhile,
like we had to start drinking now.
That was brutal.
But I mean,
you know how much I tried to micromanage that behind the scenes.
Right?
Like I was
trying to figure that out.
And you,
you guys basically broke all the rules.
I thought I laid down and Ilan [inaudible],
Ilan tweeted y'all be on Joe's podcast Thursday night at 9:00 or whatever.
So,
but,
you know,
I mean,
I didn't want you guys to go live.
I wanted,
I wanted you to both have a chance to say,
wait a minute,
this is smoking a blunt,
really the thing we want to be doing here.
Uh,
so,
you know,
you didn't take my advice and it was what it was when we were drunk by the time
that we'd came out.
That was what's,
what's interesting to me is we were drinking from the beginning of the podcast.
We started drinking whiskey.
We both had two or three glasses of whiskey before the weed came out.
Nobody cared.
The fact that the CEO of Tesla was drunk,
like no one cared about that.
I mean,
it wasn't drunk,
but he shouldn't have been driving.
I don't know if that was obvious.
I don't know if they saw that you were drinking.
It was obvious in the beginning,
pouring the whiskey.
I mean,
it was on the table.
We had ice.
We're clinking glasses,
salute.
I mean it was very obvious.
I mean,
the problem for me there with that podcast,
frankly it was that I feel like you both got unlucky with,
which is where he was in his life at that moment because it.
So what that podcast showcased,
at least for the first,
I don't know,
90 minutes was just how many user interface problems you could have with Elon.
Right.
Like he just showed up as,
as kind of fairly weird,
right?
He's not,
he's not always like that by any stretch.
I mean he can give a very loose interview and.
But you were working.
I mean it was just absolutely heroic work trying to keep that conversation
happening in the beginning.
But once we got loose,
yeah,
that was good.
But it was still,
you know,
he was just in a space that he was so massively stressed and so overworked and
just.
I mean he had,
you know,
fires everywhere that had to be put out.
And so I just felt,
you know,
as a friend,
I just felt like,
okay,
this is sort of the wrong time to be doing this.
And so I just felt,
you know,
it just felt unlucky to me.
So,
um,
because he's,
uh,
again,
I,
you know,
I see him in,
in many other moments and he can be,
if that was out,
there was actually a circumstance where I was looking at the comments,
right?
You know,
and,
and Alice saying,
okay,
these are,
these are people who are basically reading him as somebody who is,
is much stranger than in fact he,
he ever is.
And I could see why they were doing that because he,
the guy,
he just seemed in a very stressed space in his life.
What was interesting,
he was very different when you first got here versus when the Mike came on right
when he first got here,
he pulls out the fucking blow torch and starts shooting this flame thrower in
the middle of the hallway.
And we're laughing and I'm like,
he's going to be easy.
This is great.
And then we sat down and then right off the bat and,
um,
I'm just trying to massage it and get them,
get them,
get them going.
Although I honestly,
I think that is another consequence of live.
I mean,
I'm not,
I'm not arguing that you shouldn't be live because it,
it has a massive advantage for you as well,
but it is,
there's just a different feeling.
If I knew that this was being taped and I could rethink the thing we're about to
say about Liam Neeson or whatever it is,
you know,
it's,
it's different.
And so,
um,
but will the Liam Neeson story is a perfect example there.
Okay.
Yeah,
let's go.
They're a perfect example of a story where,
you know,
if you are Liam's friend,
you would go toe.
Tell that one.
Don't tell that one he's like,
but I want to be honest,
like don't,
don't,
you could be honest with me.
I'm not going to judge you if you tell me that someone got raped and you went
out with a baseball bat for a week looking for a black man to beat up on the
hill to kill.
I'd be like,
oh Jesus Christ man.
Like what the fuck was going through your head at that point in time?
Like,
that's terrible.
Yeah.
Like,
I feel awful about it,
I can't believe that was me,
but it didn't happen.
Nothing happened.
And now you know,
people are calling him a racist and they don't want them in movies.
And.
Well,
I mean,
this is,
this is fascinating to me because again,
this is a much larger problem with massive implications.
We need to think through the whole process of redemption for people in our
society,
right?
Like,
like we,
we have to understand what are the,
what are the criteria for successful apologies and for forgiveness or like just
what,
because especially,
I mean,
we're in,
we're in a world where people are having their reputations destroyed in their
careers,
threatened for tweets,
they sent us teenagers yet.
Right?
And,
and you know,
more this,
this is the dorseys point.
Things are not disappearing online anymore.
In a certain point.
You know,
everyone is going to be a three 60 kind of panopticon view of everyone's life.
there are people who have grown up on social media and everything is out there.
And,
um,
I mean,
the irony here for me is that you have progress progressives and the people on
the far left who received a disclosure like,
you know,
Liam Neeson's justice take his and they just want,
they just want to see him burned alive,
right?
A little,
let's just do the wicker man on this guy because this is,
this is so awful.
And yet alongside that,
the same people on the left are people who have as a,
as a genuine ethical norm,
the rehabilitation of murderers,
or you could be somebody who spent 20 years in prison for a crime you admit,
you committed and there's this norm around redemption.
And uh,
so there's,
you know,
there's no way to square those two things.
They're constantly holding news to two contradictions,
right?
I mean,
here's another one,
women's rights and supportive.
The Hijab,
I mean,
yeah,
this is what's going on there.
How do you do that?
You know,
don't be Islamophobic,
but also support women's rights and gay rights.
Okay.
Well,
I think Eric Weinstein,
our mutual friend calls these,
the,
um,
the Hilbert problems for social justice warriors.
And David Hilpert was a very famous mathematician who at,
at,
at the turn of the 19th century,
posed a set of problems in mathematics that,
you know,
we're just,
the,
on his list of the most desirable questions that they like the hardest questions
and the most consequential questions to answer.
And so,
you know,
Eric has been a mathematician,
has flipped that around ironically and said these were,
these were the questions that social justice warriors have to answer and there
are these impossible oppositions of this sort.
But,
so the Liam Neeson thing,
and,
you know,
forgive me if I,
if there's some detail that has come out that I'm not aware of,
but my understanding of it is he,
you know,
he had a friend who was raped and then he reported this state of mind,
this murderous state of mind he was in where he was walking around with a few.
He calls it a cautious.
I'm a British word for like a,
like a small metal club,
right?
Um,
it was like a black jack or another term for it,
I think.
And I'm looking for a black guy to kill your life,
doesn't hoping someone's going to come out of the woodwork and threatened him so
that he could kill this guy in this act of instrumental violence because his
friend had been raped by a black guy.
Right?
So it's like any black I will do now,
that's likely the extra horrific wrinkle to the story right now.
And he's confessing this as a kind of a symptom of transient mental illness,
at least as far as I know.
It's like a.
he's horrified by the fact that he was in the state of mind.
Right?
Can you imagine like Aida,
Liam Neeson it actor.
I have everything to lose.
And although I don't remember at what point in his life he said this happened.
Can you imagine that?
I was in the state of mind.
Right?
And this is,
as you say,
at an all too honest disclosure,
but it is damn interesting.
Right?
And it is the kind of thing that we should be able to talk about.
And it's not an the fact that this is becoming synonymous with racism seems just
wrong given given how he's two he described,
or at least how I've,
I've heard this because he's saying,
listen,
if this had been an Armenian guy or an Italian or a Japanese guy,
I'd be looking for one of them,
right?
I mean,
what,
what this was,
at least on his telling is the virus of instrumental violence.
I mean,
the Va,
the virus of like,
this is how every blood feud ever in human history gets started.
Like you,
like someone from your tribe killed my brother.
And now what I want to do is kill anyone from your tribe,
right?
Doesn't matter who you are.
And,
and that's,
you know,
clearly as toxic as it gets,
ethically.
But that's not racism,
right?
That's just,
that is that we have a word for it.
It's an instrumental violence.
Um,
but,
you know,
yeah,
obviously he's getting totally pilloried over this,
but we need,
we just need to figure out how to talk about how people can redeem themselves
once something this unsavory is,
is revealed about their past.
Whether they reveal it or whether it's just,
you know,
found out about them.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean,
it is racism though,
Ryan,
because he's specifically looking for a black guy.
I mean,
I understand that it's a part of the other tribe.
No,
but it doesn't suggest that he has,
that he dispose that he feels one way or another about black people.
It's like,
like if you told me,
um,
uh,
yeah,
he,
he could,
he could have said again,
it could have been a,
an Irish guy,
right?
Or it could have been mental.
I guess he's Irish.
He's,
he's a Scottish or Irish.
Um,
it could have been an English guy.
Right.
It could've been like any type.
It's like the salience of the tribe is what he was reacting to,
at least in his description.
I don't know why you wouldn't take him at his word given that he didn't have to
say any of this in the first place.
Right.
I mean,
like,
this is an amazingly honest and unnecessary disclosure,
but it's,
um,
and I don't think people would think of it as racism if he,
if the story simply was a,
she got raped by a cop and I was just hoping to go kill a cop.
Right.
The same story.
Um,
and,
uh,
so yeah,
but we're so trigger happy in our outrage with respect to anything.
Why do you think that is?
Like what,
what is going on?
Because outrage seems to be more in season than it's ever been in my lifetime.
I don't,
I don't ever remember outrage being so just such a.
it's,
it's recreational.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a,
I mean it's back to Jack.
I mean it's a lot.
It has a lot to do with social media and twitter in.
Yeah,
I mean you have.
So for instance,
I missed the whole Covington highschool Catholic fiasco not onto basically was
ignoring twitter.
I saw it,
saw it out of the corner of my eye,
like men,
this is interesting,
this is,
this is blowing up,
but I,
I was so off twitter that I had,
there was no temptation for a hot take from me.
Right.
And I saw these people just torching their reputations by taking these,
like Kathy Griffin basically calling for the docs and have these kids,
you know,
given all that she has suffered from,
from mob behavior online and she's whipping up her own mob.
It was just nuts,
but it's normal.
That's what people do.
It's what the platform is calling out of people,
but it's also when people have been shamed and they've done something awful.
Then they reinforce their base like that.
Now she's like his so heavily hard left because the right wing ran after her.
Like anyone on the right that does anything.
She's calling for her side to go after this person.
Like reinforcing that she's a part of that tribe,
that she's a part of that left wing tribe.
Yeah.
Well it's.
So obviously everyone has a lot to lose doing this,
especially in a case where all the facts aren't in and if you just waited a beat
and even the New York Times got this wrong,
the New York Times writes an article about the kids in the Maga hat that they
have to resend.
And the.
So then as the dust is settling and I see these people,
some people are doubling down,
some people are issuing public apologies.
I see somebody who's actually kind of branded herself as one of my enemies for
some reason I can't fathom.
But this journalist Kara Swisher,
uh,
who,
um,
you know,
she,
she works for a recode and vox now,
but she's got a big podcast and she's a,
she actually writes for the New York Times.
Now she's got an opinion piece,
a regular column for the New York Times.
She's a tech journalist.
And I happened to know she doesn't like me because she's tweeted against,
you know,
she's said some disparaging things about me on twitter and we had an offline
conversation about it.
Uh,
but I saw her,
she said one of the most vituperative and fairly crazy things in response to the
kids initially and then once more information came out,
she walked it back and she basically apologized,
you know,
good for her twitter.
And so,
so I said,
good for you Cara.
I just wanted to,
to support this norm of acknowledging that you got something wrong.
And I wanted to do it even I wanted to actually do it for someone who I know
really doesn't like me.
Like,
I mean,
that was an added bonus for me because that's,
that's a,
that's another norm that I think we should support.
It's like,
like we should,
we should play fair even with our enemies.
And I mean honestly,
I,
you know,
I try to play fair even with people who never play fair with me.
Even someone like Glenn Greenwald or raise ocelot,
I mean people who have just lied about me endlessly.
If I get something wrong about them,
I publicly apologized for it.
Um,
so I did this and this was at the absolute 11th hour with respect to this,
this,
uh,
you know,
scandal online and when I saw the kind of pain I was getting just for,
supporting Kara in her walk back of this thing we had at a moment when it was
obvious she should have walked this back.
I got people saying,
you know,
unsubscribing from your podcast,
you are,
you know,
now I know you're a fucking racist,
it was just,
I just sure pain and I just thought,
wow man,
that's,
you know,
it's like you just touched this thing at the very end and you're,
you're,
you know,
it's the slime gets on you.
Um,
so yeah,
it is,
it's the medium.
We have no opportunity to do this before it is the medium and it's also people
that don't feel like their opinions are being heard.
Like they want their opinion to be heard.
They want it to be heard right now.
And it might not be a very well thought out opinion,
but they know that they have the ability to blare it out.
And so they
just send it out and that,
that,
the ability to do that,
it's just intoxicating for folks and they'll reach you.
You talk about this with Jack.
There is a.
What makes twitter especially good for this is that everything has the same
stature,
like your tweets no bigger than the other tweet that just called you an asshole.
That's my Kurt Metzger.
Take on it because Kurt Metzger was a hilarious standup comedian.
He,
uh,
he'll write a facebook blog only.
He only writes on facebook.
He's like,
I like how it's set up.
it's,
there's a big.
It differentiates between me and these fucking idiots who are commenting under
there have.
Although ironically,
I hate facebook.
I can't even,
I mean just the graphic design on facebook,
I find so offensive that I can't even look at facebook.
So I use it as a publishing channel.
But I,
you know,
I keep threatening in my own mind to just delete the account because I just
don't.
I've only read the comments three times maybe ever read them.
It's like choose Christ.
It's like youtube,
but alive.
I know it's like youtube,
but with people with their real names,
it's,
you know,
this is a new world that we're living in man,
and everybody's trying to navigate this thing and figure it out as it goes
along.
And not everybody's doing it well.
And uh,
I think this world is going to get more and more intrusive.
I think this is just the beginning.
I think we didn't see twitter coming,
whatever comes after twitter.
And this is one of the things that I,
before the podcast I wanted to really talk to jack about to get his take on what
he thinks is next down the line because there's going to be something that's
more invasive.
It's going to be something that is more,
whether it's a,
I think probably something in the line of augmented reality.
There were probably a decade away from something that makes this look like books
look like,
you know,
a fucking corkboard at a bookstore.
Although strangely we're live.
We're living through the golden age of audio here.
It's like we went full into video and we're poised to go like,
you know,
three d and Vr.
And then all of a sudden audio is king.
Well,
how about phone calls and texts?
Like I remember I called you out of the blue ones and it was like,
what the fuck what you
walk into a supermarket.
Somebody said on twitter once.
It was hilarious.
That facetiming face timing me out of nowhere.
It just like knocking on my door without calling me straight up.
She was angry that somebody face timed her.
No,
it always feels like an old school move to my book.
Agent calls me out of the blue and it's just seems so old.
It is just like a knock on the door.
My friend Joey Diaz only calls only for years.
He would scream at you if you text.
And then recently within the last two or three years you started texting
occasionally.
But he only calls.
Well I gotta I gotTa tell you I haven't released this meditation APP has given
me a kind of a sanity check on everything else I'm doing.
Which is very interesting because in releasing the APP,
you know,
it's like it's firewalled from all the other controversial stuff I'm doing.
I'm like,
I'm not in the APP,
I'm not whinging about trump or you know,
talking about any of the stuff I talk about on my podcast is just me trying to
teach meditation as a largely as an antidote to all of this stuff we're talking
about.
It's like we've got,
this is Tristan Harris says we've got the slot machine in our pocket that is
continually gaming our attention all day long and in my view a meditation app is
like the one thing you can have on your smartphone that completely subverts the
technology and you can get you to actually live a more examined life using the
technology.
But what's been amazing for me personally is that I put it out and it is the
only thing that I have put out maybe ever right where it has been received
exactly as I've intended.
Right?
There's no controversy.
It's just like,
like the people who are finding it useful,
love it and they say thank you,
and it's like they're,
they're,
they're getting exactly what I thought I was putting into it and it's like,
it made me think,
what the hell am I doing over here with all of this toxic stuff that has been
endlessly,
endlessly maliciously spawn against me and misunderstood and you know,
was just,
man,
I have to,
I have to do both because there's a lot of important things to talk about that
are going to be endlessly spawn and,
and malicious.
Slandered,
misunderstood.
But it is,
it's been so refreshing to have one thing.
I mean you must get this with,
with,
you know,
you're doing your standup or,
or maybe I don't have a thing.
I get shit for everything.
Okay.
But well maybe.
Maybe UFC commentary.
They come after me for everything.
Well he is just,
it has been psychologically it's been a revelation to have one thing that I can
put out that is just,
it's just received appreciated.
And they got what I intended and it's just,
you know,
thank you.
It's just like,
oh fuck,
that's possible.
I had no idea I had.
If I ever knew I had forgotten that that w that was possible.
Well,
meditation now it kind of makes sense because the people who are going to flock
to that are looking to meditate.
They're looking to improve their mind.
They're not looking to spew hatred on facebook.
No.
I thought that after the podcast with Jack,
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
I should just stick to podcast with comics because podcast with comics,
even if you put your foot in your mouth,
everybody knows you're just trying to be funny.
Right.
You know if you do a podcast and and the thing about the podcast with Jack,
it's not even,
like I said anything bad,
it's what I didn't say that that was upsetting to so many people,
but that's such a loaded thing and because of that podcast,
now there's negative to it that blow back.
There's a lot of toxic anger and all that,
but the positive is what I like.
The positive that came out of it is me forced to reexamine how I do podcast,
reexamined the significance of each individual guests and especially someone
that comes with as much baggage know,
without lack of a better term,
a as Jack that you're,
you know,
you gotta think that there's people listening and there's some questions that
you really have to work at.
You have to,
you have to push through and even if he's,
he's dancing and peer wedding,
I should've went back to,
okay,
why is Kathy Griffin on your platform?
Like if doxing is bad,
you want,
you don't want to docs,
you don't want threats of violence.
When someone says,
I want names,
okay,
what are you going to do with these fucking names?
What are you gonna do with them?
What are you gonna do with a 16 year old kid and his names and then when you see
the actual,
the actual video of what actually happened and there's so many people that are
still not walking it back still no doubling down.
A lot of people doubled down.
Fuck him.
And here's another little piece of insight.
My friend Matt lived in DC and those hats,
those magazines,
they're fucking everywhere.
There's these little where these kids were that area.
There's these carts that sell these hats,
so these kids bought those hats that day.
It's not like they're these mag a kids.
They'd probably just be an assholes right there,
unsupervised teenage boys.
Their frontal lobe is not fully formed and they're all together feeding off each
other like a pack of Gremlins.
I was a teenage boy.
You were a teenage boy.
You know how fucking stupid used to be.
I mean,
I was probably way more stupid than you,
but I was a mess.
I had my moments now it'd be just you get 100 teenage boys together in a crowd,
you know,
on a school trip and you get some native elder drumming in one of the in some
guys face.
It was amazing what didn't happen.
Exactly.
No violence,
no violence,
and no.
The way he handled it.
Oh,
you did a smile.
So listen,
I'm as biased as anyone against a Catholic school kid wearing a Maga hat given.
Given my backstory is like,
yeah,
I'm totally poised.
I think this guy's an asshole and this likely always to be an asshole.
But what people read into an uncomfortable smile,
right?
I mean,
just like the,
the,
the shots
of his face with the tweets that said,
you know,
this is what white privilege looks like.
This is,
you know,
this is,
this is the,
everything that's wrong in our society.
It's just,
we have to slow down.
How about raise road?
If you ever seen a more entrepreneur,
punchable face,
come on man.
You want to punch him because he's smiling with his me started on,
uh,
calls for violence from the left are so fucking disturbing to me because my
parents were hippies when I grew up.
I always thought of the left and we always,
I've been called,
right?
We have never voted anything but democratic in my life except for Gary Johnson.
Gary Johnson was the only time I voted independent or whatever the fuck he was
libertarian.
But that was just [inaudible].
He did my podcast.
I've often Tulsi Gavin because he did my podcast,
but the,
the,
the left was always very considerate.
Well read.
They were,
there were the people that were more openminded,
there were supporting of gay people and minorities that was the left and then
were nonviolent.
They were the people that are protesting Vietnam when I was a kid.
Also just supportive of the virtue of speech and free speech and self criticism.
Yes.
I mean that the,
the,
the disadvantage of the left against the right has always been there's this self
scrutiny and willingness to wonder whether or not I'm wrong,
that isn't mirrored if you go far enough.
Right.
And uh,
it has,
there has been.
So there's been kind of an asymmetric war between left and right,
you know,
politically from,
for much of our lifetime,
but you go far enough left now and you're,
you're meeting a kind of totalitarian resistance to speech and it's.
Yeah,
it's very,
I mean I'm just,
it'll be interesting to see how the,
the 2020 campaign plays out,
but I'm certainly worried that we could totally blow it with some leftist social
new uprising.
Yeah.
That would be unfortunate because I think they would just double down on the
other side.
We'd be better off with some sort of a reasonable centrist,
right.
Someone who just made sense and,
you know,
one of the things that I liked about Tulsi is that she's a veteran and,
she's,
she seems very reasonable to me,
but except that I haven't followed her career closely,
but it just seems like she's not making the right noises on things like Syria
and Assad and I don't know enough about that to comment.
I don't know enough about Assad and the controversy of whether or not he gassed
is,
whether that is,
I think uncontroversial in terms of what she mean that is uncontroversial.
Which in terms of what she is saying about it,
about him.
I mean,
she,
she's capable of putting both feet in her mouth on that and thought she's what
she's saying.
He's not an enemy of America.
Right.
So,
yeah,
I mean,
again,
I'm not close enough to it and uh,
but I,
I would be very circumspect about endorsing her going forward.
And we did do a little homework because I think her candidacy is not going to
age well.
That's,
uh,
that's my.
Who makes sense to you?
Elizabeth Warren's fucked now.
The most recent one,
she's got the most recent one for.
She filled out an application.
She wrote native American on a budget just having done the DNA test is playing
that game with trump.
I mean that was,
that was such a miscalculation.
Well,
the fact that she released the data and the data's so clear.
Well it's almost like she had to because otherwise he would call her pocahontas
to the end of time,
but that,
but then to then have to apologize to native Americans for having done the
tablet just because the amount of native American is so low.
I've been joking around about it than I am like 100 times more African and she
is native American.
I'm one point six percent African and she's less than like way less than one
percent native American.
Right.
But this,
these are,
this is the sort of masochistic death spiral that people on the left can get
into.
It's like you're on the left and I've always said that the left eats its own in
a way that the right never does.
It's just,
it's,
um,
we have to find someone who can stand outside that the circular firing squad,
right?
Uh,
and it would be someone who's,
you know,
it would be,
in my view,
would be somebody like a,
a younger Bloomberg,
right?
I mean,
I don't think it's,
I don't think it's Bloomberg,
but like somebody,
like a legit businessman who could call bullshit on all of trump's fake business
acumen and who's not ethically compromised.
Right?
But who can,
who can get stuff done and so,
and,
and definitely not someone who feels the need to pander to the far left on these
identity politics issues.
I think identity politics is really going to be bad for us against trump because
so much of the country,
the crucial sliver of the country.
And you just have to ask yourself who was it who voted for Obama and then or
twice and then voted for trump.
Right?
Those people aren't racist,
right?
Those people are sick of being called racist.
Right.
And the,
what's happening on the left around identity politics and all of these.
I mean,
it's not that racism isn't a problem,
is not that transgender issues don't have to be worked out and be like all like
all of those are legit concerns,
but the fact that that's the center of mass politically on the left,
in,
in a nationwide election against someone like trump.
I just think that's an absolute recipe for disaster because the people that
subscribed to that ideology don't realize how many people think it's silly.
Yeah.
You know,
when you're in the oppression Olympics and you're trying to win the gold and for
and for how many people it's actually misapplied.
It's like there,
there are many more explanations for voting for trump in addition to racism.
But like,
yeah,
like,
yes,
every racist voted for trump,
you know,
virtually.
So that's fine.
Every white supremacist voted for trump,
but that's not the story about why trump got elected and song store.
It's just much more.
I mean,
there's people who just have not,
um,
what do you mean?
Ours are not thriving in the current economy and stuff like that.
You got automation displacing manufacturing jobs.
You got the consequences of trade and immigration.
And,
uh,
you have legitimate concerns about,
you have a legit,
there are legitimate concerns about immigration that have nothing to do with
racism.
And so if you're going to score any hesitation over something like open borders
as a sign of your xenophobia and racism,
you're going to lose virtually everyone who has a sane concern about how to,
how you keep people in,
how you,
how you admit the right people into a country,
right?
I mean,
there are economic concerns and there are social concerns.
And,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
and you don't have to be Ben Shapiro to share some of those concerns.
Right?
And I'm not saying bench appears racist,
obviously I'm saying he's a conservative,
uh,
and you know,
take some more conservative line on,
on many of these questions than I do,
but you know,
it's like,
you either you either think,
but just take immigration is the narrow case.
You either think you should be able to know who's coming into the country or you
don't right now,
if you,
if you think you should just have open borders,
uh,
there are two problems with that.
One is there are many good arguments against that and to,
I don't know what the percentage is,
but it's got to be something like 95 percent of Americans would be terrified at
that prospect.
Right?
So if you're,
if,
if any of your platform is essentially saying it,
concerned about immigration is synonymous with racism,
you know,
you have a platform that is going to alienate most people and that's what the
Democrats are totally capable of seeming like that.
Whether in fact that's,
that's true for most Democrats.
What do you think is,
what's the primary factor like what,
what caused identity politics through reached this boiling point that it's at
right now?
Well,
it is.
I think in large measure what the Internet is doing to us,
it's not that identity.
Politics has been a feature of politics for forever,
but there is a,
there's the silo effect.
There's the effect that groups become more radicalized the as groups because the
most extreme voices tend to,
to pipe up more and then and,
and everyone.
Everyone who's who is silent.
I mean,
there's kind of a diffusion of responsibility around,
around countering these extreme voices,
like a,
you know,
every you can,
it only takes a small percentage of extreme voices to cow the rest of the group
and,
and make the group seem like the extreme voices are speaking for the group,
you know,
and,
and so I think what we have on in the left and the right,
we have a small percentage.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
the last poll I saw that trying to get at this question was something like,
six or eight percent on the tails that are making it seem like these are,
I think it's,
I think it's more of a problem on the left than on the right because I mean,
the extreme right stay is fringe and looks fringe,
right?
Like the guy,
the guys in Charlottesville,
Charlottesville with their Tiki torches,
they don't look like they represent the Republican Party or the,
or the,
the,
um,
the right,
the conservatives in any general sense.
Um,
there are a symptom of some problem,
but it's a smaller problem.
It's a minority problem.
Whereas on the left,
the extreme voices are,
have massive sway in major companies in tech companies,
in journalism,
in academia,
like,
like the silencing effect and the reputational cost that's being paid by even
very powerful people in all these mainstream forums on the left is,
is just,
that's not mirrored on the right,
you know,
and it's.
I mean,
so I don't know if I told you this,
I'm certainly didn't say it on a,
on a previous podcast with you,
but,
so it was,
I was at dinner with a bunch of Silicon Valley people and we were talking about,
I,
I was,
it was at the moment when that,
that Netflix story happened where the,
um,
where Jonathan Friedland got fired over using the n word in a closed door
meeting.
And it was,
it was,
uh,
using the n word in response to my friend Tom Segura who you.
Oh yeah,
right.
Exactly.
Special.
Where he said you can't say retarded anymore.
And then explained like that,
you know,
there's words you can't use anymore.
I didn't even wasn't using it in a joke,
like calling someone retarded or saying something's retarded,
but they were in,
he was saying that that's like using the envelope around.
Yeah.
But he used the n word in this meeting,
right.
And it says like using the n word and the,
just the,
the,
the mere intonation of those syllables was so shocking.
Right?
Uh,
that he wound up getting fired.
Right.
And,
and again,
he was,
he was using it in the context of expressing just how careful netflix has to be
about speech and he was going social justice warrior on himself among social
justice warriors.
And he said this is how worried we have to be.
And that it gave a magic incantation.
You can still say retarded,
which is amazing because it's stiff.
I mean,
in his defense you kind of have to say both words.
You're not saying the R word,
right?
Like using the r word is,
uh,
like using the n word around black people.
More getting to some weird fucking weird place with this.
Actually,
no.
Now I'm realized why I'm confused about why I think I've talked about this
because I did a podcast with Chelsea handler,
which hasn't aired,
I mean,
did it months ago,
um,
because she was doing a documentary on white privilege I think.
And I,
I think I'm actually cast as the guy with white privilege and this documentary.
Boy,
that's going to be fun.
You have white privilege.
Yeah.
Nice.
So,
um,
uh,
but I,
I recorded a podcast with her.
So anyway,
so we hit this point because this had just come out,
uh,
then.
And I think her documentary is probably for Netflix.
So what was her take on it?
Well,
she was,
she was basically,
I mean she was playing the other side of the net for this,
you know,
and you know,
not,
um,
we'll,
we'll have to see.
I mean,
I think I,
uh,
it,
at least in my own mind,
I certainly made sense there and she shouldn't have a lot of response to what I
was saying,
but I,
I haven't heard the audio or seeing the video.
Uh,
but the,
um,
so anyway,
I was at a dinner with a bunch of tech ceos talking about this problem and one
guy who I won't name,
who runs a big company,
which I won't name,
I said,
listen,
you have no idea how deep this goes.
Like I have an hr complaint where,
uh,
there's a guy who identifies as a furry,
he thinks he's a cat and because we don't provide litter boxes in the bathroom,
right?
He's,
he's launched an HR complaint,
right.
This is real,
this is real.
This was told as a real story in,
in,
as a counterpoint or in,
in amplification of the story we were talking about it.
Netflix,
right?
So it's like this is,
this is happening like this is people are having to navigate ceos of
multimillion dollar companies are having to navigate around this stuff in house.
Right.
And I mean,
the Google thing over James Demore,
right?
I mean that was,
that was an enormous problem for Google,
right?
Like that was the wheels were coming off as far as I can tell from what I've
heard what and how.
So just that,
like there was a,
there was going to be a google mutiny over James Damore if he was,
he has be fired.
Yeah.
This was,
this was a big deal at Google.
That's what he and what he wrote was essentially like a,
you know,
a b plus term paper and human biology.
Right.
And it was like in May you can,
you can,
you can push back on some of the science,
say or.
But like this was not a malicious distortion of the state of the science.
And,
and this was not calling for discrimination against women.
This was just saying,
listen,
men and women are different and they've got different interests.
Right?
And this could account for why there's an unequal representation at the left
level of software and software development.
Uh,
and so we're like,
we're on the left.
We're finding it very difficult to even talk about differences between men and
women.
Right.
That there's,
you know,
start with,
start with a uterus and then count from there.
Right.
That is already a taboo conversation to have and that,
you know,
as we said at the beginning in talking about twitter,
that one writer again,
I,
her name is Megan Murphy,
she got booted for saying men are not women.
Yeah.
But that's.
So,
so again,
this was politically,
I'm very worried that unless we resolve that or just cut through it,
uh,
we don't stand a chance against trump in 2020.
I was reading a story about a woman who was on some sort of an Lbgt,
uh,
panel and uh,
she's a part of some group and she was kicked out of it by a man who identifies
as a lesbian and he has a penis.
Right?
Right.
Yeah,
exactly.
What ironically,
so this is the point that he has a penis.
I want to be sure he definitely identifies as a lesbian that I might've read a
twitter comment about how preposterous that was inside the penis part.
This is something that Andrew Sullivan wrote in a recent article on this is that
the transgender thing is at odds with gay rights in a fundamental sense and that
you can't balance these equations because like two gay identity absolutely
focuses on the legitimate differences between men and women.
It's like I'm a man,
I like men,
I like women.
That's my situation.
But once you,
once you change the,
your,
your notion of what,
you know,
how gender relates to sex,
it,
it begins to erode this claim on the legitimacy of,
of,
uh,
of a gay identity is that they're all marginalized so they stick together.
That's the idea,
I guess behind it.
But there's something I can only imagine what,
you know,
Andrew Sullivan's twitter feed looks like now because he,
when he writes these articles,
I'm sure he's just gets eviscerated by the left and he's just,
you know,
straight up talking about,
this is what gay rights looks like and this is,
this is how you can't be a,
a man with a penis who's identifies as a lesbian.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
But you can't say that.
Oh,
and you also can't say that a man with a penis is not a woman because if a man
with a penis,
I can say it because I can't be fired,
but if you do say it,
you will get a certain amount of hate.
I mean,
there's people that are saying that men who will not date trans women who still
have penises,
they're transphobic,
transphobia.
And this is,
I mean,
there's.
Have you ever,
uh,
have you ever met Jamie Kilstein?
So Jamie and I have a checkered history.
I don't know if maybe you and I have spoken about this.
I've never met Jamie,
but Jamie,
when Jamie was social justice warrior,
number one,
he went hard.
He went hard on me.
Like he,
he just,
he was dunking on me endlessly in ways that were totally unfair.
I mean,
he was just,
he was,
he was working very hard to become an enemy.
And um,
then he had his,
his epiphany of then the social justice mob came for him
over something for almost nothing over him trying to get laid.
I mean,
like they were saying he was a creep or something like that,
just try hitting on girls.
I miss the details there,
but then he came then.
So then he since sent me very,
uh,
friendly and apologetic emails about Josie.
I'm sorry,
what I did.
And,
and you know,
he,
he wants,
he wants to do a podcast.
I haven't taken them up on it,
but,
um,
you know,
that,
that maybe that could be an interesting conversation.
Sincerely apologetic.
He's a good guy.
I mean,
he,
he and I had our own issue at one point in time over a podcast that we did
versus,
uh,
it was,
you remember when the Daniel Tosh rape controversy like,
uh,
do you,
do you remember this?
I know who talked about,
I missed the joke,
I should say rape joke.
Some woman in a crowd.
He was,
he was on stage and he wasn't supposed to be there.
It was at the laugh factory.
And Dom,
I rera put them on stage and he goes,
look,
I don't have any material.
What do you guys want to talk about?
And some guy yells out,
rape.
And uh,
that's always helpful.
And so,
you know,
it's like some drunk and a crowd.
He goes,
she's crazy late.
And so Daniel tosh his take on it.
Okay.
What,
what's funny about that humiliation,
violence,
you know,
he's,
he's like berating,
this guy is trying to do standup while he's doing this.
And some woman yells out,
actually there's nothing funny about rape.
And he goes,
wouldn't it be funny if someone who just raped her and everybody starts laughing
or do you remember this woman wrote a giant blog about it and she wanted him to
apologize about it.
And Jamie went after Daniel Tosh as a fellow,
as a fellow comic saying that it's,
you know.
And I was like,
well,
she's a heckler.
The women women heckled,
like while he was trying to do to stand up and he's like,
I'm not going to support rape culture.
And he's like,
how the fuck is that rape culture?
Like he's,
he's clearly making a joke about something she said that was very,
very patronizing.
Like obviously he doesn't think there's something funny about rape.
This is,
he's just trying to work through this ad Lib set that he's doing with some guy
who yelled out something that this whole crowd has to respond to.
He can't just ignore the fact that it happened and go,
how about firetrucks,
folks?
Why?
They always read now he can't do that.
He's gotTa.
He's got deal with what this guy sat and so that's what he tosses out there and
everybody laughed by the way,
but also isn't the priority of his persona persona.
Just a villain.
He takes it to the edge,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
He's,
yeah,
he's edgy comedian.
He's funny and you know,
Jamie and I had this little tit for tat about it,
but he,
he's very honest about his mistakes.
Like when you talked to him and he's,
he's got great insight because he was that guy,
you know,
he was that guy that was going back and forth with people online all day and
checking is mentioned,
like couldn't walk down the street more than five steps before he'd pull out his
phone and check has mentioned how people responding to as late as Duncan take
down or you know,
it's just,
it's a toxic thing that people are doing.
It's this,
this,
you know,
looking for people that are,
that are bad and looking for things that are wrong,
looking for wrong speak.
It's very toxic.
It's toxic for the people that are doing it.
It's toxic for the people that are receiving it.
It's just,
it's not a way that human beings would ever communicate in one on one.
I mean,
I tried to communicate with people the same way online as I would have.
They're right in front of me.
I don't always succeed,
but I try.
That's my goal.
My goal is to try to talk to someone as if they were right in front of me.
That's clearly not how everybody's handling.
I think road rage is the is the best analogy for what's happening on social
media.
I've adopted that,
have adopted that way of looking at it too,
and the only difference is a road rage.
You know,
there's like a physiological reason for road rage because you're,
you're,
you're in a dangerous situation that you're subliminally taking stock going
fast.
You're going to a metal machine with a bunch of assholes that are probably
looking at their phone and everybody's going fast and you could die at any
moment if someone goes wrong.
If you're on a highway like the four,
oh five,
when you have five lanes going 70 miles an hour,
it is a fucking miracle that no one dies.
And everyday we do it every day.
Everything's fine.
Yeah.
Well,
so let's go back to this idea of what the,
the actual normative response would be when somebody puts their foot in their
mouth or something from their past gets disclosed.
I mean the,
the,
the stupid and indefensible thing they did as a teenager,
right?
Yeah.
You know this,
you know,
you've got these guys who are now having their careers destroyed for having
dressed up in black face or neck in a,
in a hood for Halloween or whatever it was.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I think,
I think this,
that one politician said he's not even in the,
in the photo,
but the photo was on his yearbook page or like whatever you put on your yearbook
page in high school,
right?
You find out this thing that,
you know,
adult is going to defend,
right?
But what is the path back?
What?
Like what?
Like what is the reboot that,
what that should be acceptable because we don't even know.
It seems.
We don't even know what
could conceivably work to rehabilitate somebody career.
And yet on this other side,
we've got people who again are being let out of prison for murders.
They admit they committed,
right?
Or rapes,
they admit,
admit they committed and they're rehabilitated.
And we did.
And these are,
these are stories we're supposed to feel good about,
right?
So we have to figure out how to square this.
I'm on the left and you know,
I don't know,
I mean the way I've been thinking about it is that it has to be intelligible,
how you are different from the person who committed that thing.
Right.
So like if you,
if you did something that was let's say legit racist when you were 20 and it was
like mark,
Mark Walberg is an example of this.
I mean he was running around just beating people senseless.
Right.
And for avowed racist motives.
I believe when he was a teenager he would guy lost his eye,
right?
Yeah.
So,
but,
and I think that was a,
I think I was a Vietnamese guy.
He attacked or uh,
but I mean he was just doing truly indefensible things.
Now I don't know what sort of know pr moment he has had since or how he's
apologized for it or.
But I mean that was a,
as a very different time.
I think if it was,
if all that stuff was being discovered about him now there may be no way back
to.
Well my problem is with this day and age it could be reignited.
Like even though he's apologized for it and even though that it's been
addressed,
it absolutely get reignited image just made talking about on your podcast is
fucking him over.
Could.
Yeah.
I mean and also people have to recognize that there's some things that you can't
retroactively instill today's ideas of what constitutes racism on 1985.
So if you were in high school in 1985 and you dressed up as Mr t that you know,
I don't know if that was racist back then.
I never did it,
but I don't know if that's racist.
Like if you had a bunch of gold chains and you made your hair black and are you
making you made your face black and gave herself a Mohawk.
He said,
I'm Mr t for Halloween and the pictures emerged today.
What you did when you went door to door when you were 15 or 12 or whatever,
you were knocking on people's doors and everybody was laughing.
Oh you're Mr. t nobody thought it was racist,
but let's take.
Let's take the hard case.
Let's say you were racist,
right?
I mean,
so like I had this guy is a Christian pitcher,
Eleni on my podcast once who's an ex neonazis just legit racist,
right?
It's got all the tattoos to prove it.
And now their major problems with Christian pitcher Delaney as,
as,
as I think,
you know,
uh,
that I discovered after that podcast.
But,
um,
so this is not an endorsement of him,
sorry,
Christian.
But the,
the,
there's a path back.
I mean,
it's like he's celebrated on the left,
like he's a former Neo Nazi and he is,
you know,
hey,
I,
I discovered him on Sarah Silvermans a show on wherever that is,
Hulu.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
he's a darling of the left,
right at Darlene of Msnbc for this redemption story.
So,
but what is the,
you take someone like any of these politicians who have something in their
backstory that is ugly.
Uh,
my feeling is all there has to be is a transparent and intelligible account of
how you are now different of how you can actually honestly look back on this
thing and say,
yeah,
I am as embarrassed by that as you think I should be.
Right.
That's not like,
that is nothing that,
that does not represent how I view the world at all now.
But there's just the spirit of the time on social media,
again,
especially on the left and to our total dysfunction politically is to never
accept any of that.
I mean there's,
there is no apology good enough and um,
or that,
or there's,
you know,
the most cynical possible interpretation of your,
of your apology.
It's like you're just trying to,
you're the only reason why you're apologizing is because you want to save your
job.
Yes.
And that,
you know,
we have to figure out how to.
I mean,
we just need some recovery disk that we can reboot from here because it's just
not a,
this is going someplace terrible.
And again,
to look at it through the Lens narrowly politically of,
uh,
you know,
over the next two years,
it's,
it's to the massive disadvantage of the left.
It certainly is,
but I don't see any way to fix that.
Like with the current climate and this current attitude where people are
engaging in this recreational outrage,
it fits the climate.
I don't mean,
I don't know what would have to happen for people to come to some sort of a
realization.
I mean it would have to happen to them like it did to James.
Like what happened with Jamie sees,
they turned on him and he's like,
oh my God,
this is awful.
Like I'm,
what's this?
And then he realized,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know what other thing could happen,
know what we're,
the game we're playing is part of it.
I mean,
you and I are in a position to take risks that,
you know,
even the people at the top of journalism,
you can't.
I mean,
like,
like Megan Kelly says one wrong thing and you know,
it doesn't matter that she's got a $20,000,000 contract.
She's just,
she's fired.
Uh,
and when you look at the thing that she said,
I mean,
it was just a question.
Yeah.
I mean she just didn't seem to understand how charged the phrase black face was.
Right?
She's just ignorant of that piece of history or something.
But like,
you know,
so she just,
she should,
she put her foot in her mouth.
She gave an apology that was just like,
you know,
full blown hostage video apology,
just like,
you know,
just like I'm so fucking sorry.
You don't even know,
like,
here take a sample of my blood and you'll just see my task,
my cortisol and not good enough.
Not good enough.
And they let her say the apology is even more crazy.
They,
they let her come back,
say the apology and then you have good.
Thanks for doing that.
Yeah.
So,
but so she,
no one's job in that space is secure enough where they can take real risks.
But you know,
you and I,
you know,
you and I could do an interview with Louis C,
k right,
like,
and just process his coming back into stand up and do it in a way where people
didn't like it.
You just say,
okay,
fuck off.
Right.
This is the conversation we had and I think modeling that more and more.
I mean,
I think,
I think we have to take those risks and people like us have to take those risks
and hope to break the spell by having those in public.
I would hope that we're having some kind of an impact on it.
But I feel like we're,
you know,
we're throwing buckets of cold water into a volcano.
I just,
I just don't know.
I don't know if it's enough.
I just,
we have pretty big buckets.
I mean,
you have an enormous bucket.
you're,
you're reaching more people than the biggest television shows are reaching.
People aren't aware of this,
but it's just a fact.
So it's,
it's,
uh,
so I think that's part of it.
And then changing the norm somehow of how we engage on social media I think is
is another piece.
Yeah,
I agree.
I agree with you.
The norm on how we engage on social media I think is flavored by two things.
One,
the immediacy of it,
the fact that there's no person in front of you,
you don't experience their,
their anger or their fear or their sadness when you say something fucked up.
But also anonymity and I think anonymity is good in a lot of ways.
Like for whistleblowers,
people that work in a certain environment where they want to be honest,
but they would get fired,
you know,
with a very restricted environment.
But they have maybe a controversial opinion.
They want to,
they want to be able to express free speech and they can't.
They can't unless they do something anonymous.
And even sometimes people when they do things anonymous,
they get caught and they get in trouble.
Like I remember there was a guy on four Chan who was,
who would say a bunch of fucked up things like a lot of people do,
and people tracked him down and found out who he was and then sent all of these
anonymously authored posts to his employer and he got fired and this guy was a
father and he had children and he was supporting his family and now he's
struggling to make a living.
He's got to try to figure because he wrote some things anonymously online on a
message board and he found recreation and saying fucked up things,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't know what the solution is,
but I feel like anonymity,
it encourages less hospitable behavior.
Did you hear about the professor at a academic conference?
Get into an elevator and making A.
Just a dad joke of it so he gets it,
gets into a crowded elevator in an academic conference and someone asked what
floor and he says,
women's lingerie please.
Dean Martin joke or whatever.
Right.
Someone in the elevator was so offended by that,
that they lodge a complaint and I,
I've,
it's been now at least a month or so since I heard the story,
so I don't know if he was fired,
but like he was fighting for his academic life over this complaint process.
Dean Martin show.
I mean just like that,
that in the fullness of time that is going to seem like some insane which panic,
right?
Like there's no such thing as witches and yet people are getting burned alive
because of the allegations with witchcraft.
We're in that kind of situation and we,
we just have to wake up.
Yeah.
And and so,
well you and I don't teach and we're not in a,
in a university and we're not in that bubble.
I think the people that are in that bubble than the escape that bubble and go to
whatever tech company or whatever business,
they continue that same bubble like behavior and they want everybody to
acquiesce.
They want everybody around them to behave the way that they've been programmed
to think that everybody is supposed to behave.
And you see that now from a lot of young people,
you see a lot of young people who are entering into the workforce.
I think that the standards and the norms that they got enforced upon them at
Yale or Columbia,
wherever they went to school,
like this is how you're supposed to behave,
but social justice is important and this is real and you have to recognize your
privilege.
You have to check your privilege and you have to do this and you have to do that
and you have to support trans rights and you have to call out culture.
Call out culture is a big one.
That's a big part of it.
And canceled culture.
You know,
everybody wants everybody to lose their job.
You want.
I mean this is the way that things change.
The way things change is you have to reinforce the fact that there's these new
standards and it has to be severe repercussions for deviating so very,
very much about controlling.
Jordan goes on about this Jordan Peterson.
That's like one of his pet subjects.
Then yeah,
this is where this goes.
This is all about control and that it's a very slippery slope and when you start
telling people what to do and what not to do and that there's these
indefensible,
undebatable standards that have to be reinforced and you can't talk about it
like,
and that's what happened with Megan Kelly.
She said,
well how come?
And they're like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Sixty dollars million dollar job.
Again.
The crucial moment for me is
why is it that the apology isn't good enough?
That this isn't what is by all appearances,
a sincere apology.
Like,
like where the link,
there is no link to real racism.
Like there's no link to like,
oh yeah,
I want to live in a society where black people have it harder than white people.
Right?
Like,
okay,
if that,
if that's who you are,
if you're racist will then find we know we can understand why we want to boycott
your business or we want to,
you know,
you want nothing to do with you.
Right?
There should be massive.
So social pressure against those kinds of noxious political commitments.
But if someone misspeaks or it's an off color joke and they were,
it was like they weren't trying to offend anyone and they're just,
you know,
they wish they could take it back and like,
and,
and that links up with,
I mean,
did you say you must've seen the norm macdonald?
Yes.
I mean that was brutal,
right?
Like it's at what he was,
you know,
he knew he couldn't use the word retard.
Right.
Because it's like that that's going to get them in trouble.
And so,
I mean,
it's hilarious.
And explain what.
Okay.
So he was,
he was on Howard stern show,
wasn't it?
I think,
I think he was,
I could have this wrong,
but the gist of this is his right,
I believe is on the Howard stern show and he was about to use the word retard.
So,
so,
okay,
we'll walk this back now.
Now it's coming back to me.
He was defense.
He was talking about his friend that the,
the,
the ordeal that Louis Ck has gone through in this just massive exile experience,
right?
He's,
there's massive social shunning a.
and he said he,
he was describing it in a way where it,
he then got accused that he was,
he cared more about what Lucy Kay was going through,
then the women who felt very victimized by Louis C K,
and that was not his intention at all apparently.
And so when he went to,
uh,
to clarify this,
he was about to say,
you,
you'd have to be retarded to think that I cared more about Louis Ck is ordeal
than the ordeal of these women who had felt that their careers got derailed.
Right.
But as the word retard was coming or retarded was coming out of his mouth,
he tried to course correct and because he doesn't know what the fuck he's
talking about,
he says you'd have to have downs syndrome,
right?
Which is worse,
Is more specific and it's what it's like.
And then you got all these parents with Down's syndrome who,
uh,
who have kids with down syndrome who are just,
Oh my God.
And so now he's just,
he's.
Then he was,
he showed up on the view,
right with this,
this,
uh,
on this apology tour.
And I mean,
that's just amazing video to see him on the view surrounded by these,
these four women who know he's not a bad guy,
right?
Like they're trying,
they're trying to just throwing them a lifeline after lifeline and he's so
beaten down and he's so walking on eggshells and you got Whoopi Goldberg,
you know,
trying to just pull him back,
from the lions.
And
it should be.
I mean,
it should be so straightforward like it does it.
Is it part of norms,
goal to cause pain for parents who have kids with mental disabilities,
right?
No,
I mean,
like,
like you,
you can look in,
you can look into this guy's eyes for t for 10 seconds and know that this is not
the biggest you're worried about.
Of course,
you know.
And um,
and yet people just want him destroyed overnight.
I don't know if they still do,
but it's like the moment where it was,
I think it was,
uh,
a real concern that has his show would get canceled.
I me,
like this was a while.
It hasn't been for a second season and maybe that's maybe that's part of the
problem.
It is part of the problem.
He was,
he was devastated.
I mean I'm,
I'm very good friends with Adam Egan.
He's a guy that runs the comedy store,
is the talent director at the comedy store and he's been on norm show.
He was on norms.
He was like norm sidekick on the show.
He's a very good friend with nora and norm really suffered from this in a way
that he never saw anything in his career in terms of like his own personal
feeling.
Like he was devastated by it,
by the blow back and the reaction and he wanted to come on my podcast and talk
about it.
But netflix is like,
get the fuck that's like said no press.
Don't do anything.
No press.
Okay.
So the fact that you can't talk your way out of.
Yes,
that's the fucking disease.
Well,
the problem is not that you can't talk your way out of it.
The problem was that they wouldn't even let him attempt to talk your way out of
it because they think they realized that norms a maniac and norm is a maniac in
the best sense of the word is one of my favorite comics and he's fucking
hilarious,
but he's also completely crazy in the best way possible.
Right.
Norman?
I randomly in some strange way randomly were seated next to each other on two
separate flights.
Yeah,
just randomly skirt.
It's crazy.
Like nor have again,
like this is crazy and we had a great time just talking to the entire flight and
we were talking about cigarettes longer,
like,
yeah,
yeah.
I used to smoke.
I'm so glad I quit.
Fucking terrible for you.
You know?
I mean it's just.
But I just always wanted a cigarette and then it'd be gambling.
I want a cigarette,
but I quit.
Fuck,
fuck cigarettes.
Like how long did you quit?
And you're like,
oh,
I haven't had a cigarette in years.
I'm like,
oh,
that's great.
We landed lax.
He goes right into a store and buy cigarettes.
I go,
what are you doing?
He goes all that talk of cigarettes.
I just want one now.
He was lighting it on the way out the door.
He couldn't get out the door.
He lit it before he the the automatic door.
He was before it was opening.
He was lighting that cigarette.
I was like,
you're crazy.
But that's many.
Many comedians are incredibly impulsive and this is norm.
I mean he just.
He's got such a.
he's so off kilter.
He's got a sort of Garry shandling and like you don't know what's going to come
out of his mouth extemporaneously.
Yes,
but okay.
We have to be.
Let's put this back into the diversity Olympics.
We need some respect for neuro diversity.
Right?
There are people who are somewhere on the spectrum toward autism,
right?
There's people who are that there's spectrums we don't even know about.
We haven't named for sure and everyone is in some weird spot and people
misspeak.
Right?
There has to be a way back to say,
that's not what I meant.
Right.
Like,
like this is like offending people of this type was not my intention.
At some level that has to be good enough.
Unless,
you know,
we open your closet and we see that you've got swastikas everywhere,
and um,
so I think we have to,
we have to hold the line here,
you know,
and very few people are in a position to be able to do it.
I mean he's like,
you know,
Netflix,
Netflix doesn't feel they can do it.
Well,
Netflix is just so terrified of continual blowback and they just thought like,
if we're going to save this show,
the way to save it is to get them to stop talking because he's just going to
just take his other foot and take other people's feet and stuff.
Them and his mouth as well.
I think one thing that help
to illuminate our understanding of how people behave is what you really enjoy
talking about and you really definitely changed my way of looking at things that
they're really.
Essentially the concept of free will is a very flawed thing and that you have to
really take into consideration who a person is right now and what what has
caused them to be this person right now and that a lot of us are operating on
this really bizarre momentum of of our past and our behavior and our genetics
and life experiences and all these different variables that really need to be
taken into account.
This idea that you are autonomous and you are the director of your own life is
true to a certain extent,
but it's also very complicated,
much more complicated than we would like to admit and when you're talking about
something that happened when you were 17,
like Brett kavanaugh or something like that,
but Jesus Christ,
you know you're going to hold a 55,
55 year old man accountable to something that he did when he was 17.
It wasn't a crime and you're not exactly sure what happened.
That's.
This is all very strange.
This is a very strange stuff.
Well,
so taking the red pill on on freewill makes you much more forgiving of a lot of
this stuff because you see just everyone is an open system.
No one offered themselves,
no one created the themselves,
no one,
no one can directly regulate the effect of every influence that they had or
didn't have.
You know,
it's like you,
you are the totality of what brought you here.
I mean,
the universe has sort of just pushed you to this point in time and the only
thing you've got is your brain and it states and that is,
that is based on your genes and the totality of environmental influences.
You,
you're,
you had a system have,
have had working on you up until this moment.
And so the next words that come out of your mouth are part of that process.
Now the peep.
Some people find this to be,
uh,
you know,
frankly
demoralizing picture or they think,
well,
okay,
well I'm,
you're telling me,
telling me I'm just a robot,
but you're a robot that is open,
continuously open to influence,
to influence of either internally based on its own processes.
I mean,
there's like there's top down control of the executive function in the brain to
your,
you know,
your emotional life,
say,
and you're continually open to the influences of culture,
right?
You know,
the cultures as operating system that you're interacting with in each moment and
whatever's getting in can change you in radical ways very quickly.
And there's no telling how much you can change on the basis of one new idea
coming your way right now.
I would argue that that process of change,
I mean,
if I say something that changes your view on anything that's not evidence of
that is evidence of just yet more causality.
I mean,
you don't,
you don't pick the changes that come your way.
If I,
if I get you to see something that you didn't see a moment before,
you're not responsible for the fact that you didn't see it a moment before and
you're not responsible for the fact that you now see it is just like the
dominoes just kept falling,
right?
Um,
but it does give you this far more patient sense of,
um,
one,
just,
you know,
all the causes and conditions that have created the,
this,
this ods behavior.
You're,
you're,
you're now disposed to react to in the world,
right?
Like,
like you can everything on some level is,
is more of a force of nature than it is something that you need to take
personally.
It's like if there's a hurricane blowing outside,
we don't respond to it the same way we would respond to,
you know,
al Qaeda dropping a bomb on us,
right?
Because it might,
it might create the same amount of damage.
But the,
in the,
in the latter case where we have an identifiable identifiable agent,
right?
We feel like,
okay,
now we're in the presence of human evil and we have to go kill these
motherfuckers right now we may have to kill them.
Right?
Because that may be the only way of,
of,
of putting out this,
this,
you know,
stopping the damage there.
They're committed to causing.
But,
and we would kill hurricanes if we could kill them.
Right?
I mean,
we would,
you know,
we would nullify them,
but the feeling we have in both cases is very different.
The feeling you have attributing ultimate authorship to a person's behavior is
super a narrow a psychologically and ethically,
and it's,
you know,
the feeling of vengeance,
right?
Like,
like you don't,
you,
you don't,
you have this feeling of vengeance is so natural to get triggered in response to
a person.
It's not natural in response to a wild animal who may have done something
terrible.
Right?
I mean like you would like.
I mean there have been examples of this where people have taken vengeance on
animals and it just looks like a kind of moral dysfunction on the part of the
people that did it.
I mean,
there's a famous picture of a,
an elephant that got hung from a railroad crane I think back in the twenties.
Right?
So like the circus elephant escaped and it ran,
you know,
rampage through the streets and trampled by a few people and the,
and the people in the,
in the town.
I don't know where this was,
it was a baltimore or someplace were so outraged that they've decided to lynch
the elephant,
right?
Like,
and yet that's,
there's something uncanny about that sort of misappropriation of agency to an
elephant and what,
what is,
what is a mistreated circus elephant gonna do when he gets out and is terrified
and he's trying to get away from people,
it's going to trample a few people.
So we have a very different set of books we keep ethically for humans and by
some of it's understandable,
some of it's inevitable,
but a lot of it gives us moral that we don't need to have and it gives a,
it gives us a kind of
just an inability to take stock of all the variables that are actually guiding
human behavior and react to them and mitigate them and disincentivize them
intelligently.
Made punishment.
Makes Sense.
Not because people really,
really deserve at bottom whatever their punishments are.
It doesn't make sense in a,
in a retro,
retributive paradigm.
It makes sense if it,
if it's the best tool to discourage dangerous behavior,
uh,
and it works,
right?
So it's like,
you know,
if you're,
if you're going to punish people for things they can't control,
well that's stupid,
right?
Because if you,
as much as you punish them that you're not going to,
you're not going to moderate the behavior.
So you have to punish people for things that are actually under voluntary
control and it only.
It only makes sense if it's the only tool to do the job.
And if the moment you had.
I mean this may have brought this up last time we spoke about free will,
but this is really the sort of reductio ad absurdum of,
of where most people are on this topic.
The moment we really understand human evil at the level of the brain,
the moment we understand psychopathy say,
which was,
let me maybe that's not the totality of evil,
but that's certainly center of the Bullseye.
Once we understand psychopathy is a neurological condition that's governed by
genes and environment and we can,
we can actually intrude at the level of the brain to mitigate it.
So like psychopathy becomes a disease,
right?
It becomes a,
a,
an injuries syndrome,
right?
That we can fix.
And let's say it's,
let's say it's a very simple fix.
Let's say it's a pill,
right?
Let's say it's just a neurotransmitter imbalance in the presence of that
breakthrough,
we will feel very differently about that species of human evil.
We will not judge it in the same way will,
because what will happen is you'll give people the pill and they'll say,
fuck,
I can't believe I was that dangerous asshole.
Like,
like the thank you for like,
like I,
I'm as horrified by who I was before you cured me as you were right.
And it.
So it'll psychopathy and the presence of a cure for it would look much more like
diabetes than it looks like evil in the present case.
And people aren't imagining what it would like.
What would it be like to be there?
What it would be like to actually fully understand the under underlying
neurophysiology here and actually have something.
I mean,
it's,
there's no guarantee you will be able to,
to deal with it in a simple way.
But it's certainly possible.
Um,
and I mean the classic example is just like the Charles Whitman example where
you know,
you have a brain tumor that's causing this aberrant behavior.
In that case,
everyone,
everyone sees,
okay,
this is not evil.
This is a brain tumor,
that's the tower shooter games back in [inaudible] 64 I think.
And so,
but in the same way that a brain,
tuber tumors exculpatory there,
I think a full understanding of the underlying neurology would be exculpatory
again.
It doesn't mean you in the meantime,
you know,
before we get there,
we have obviously we have to lock up dangerous people if there's no way to to
help them.
But the more we see the causes,
the more we view.
We view this in terms of just sheer bad luck,
right?
Like there are,
there are people who,
when they're adults are quintessentially evil,
who we've,
who and they,
they,
they provoked the greatest feeling of engines from us.
But if you just walked back there timeline,
you recognize that at a certain they were four years old at one point,
right?
They were the four year old who was destined to become this terrible person.
It's an unlucky four year old,
you know,
and so at what point,
where's the bright line that says,
okay,
here's the point where it's appropriate to just hate this person and feel no
compassion and it on the other side of this line,
you should just feel compassion because this person's unlucky.
There is no such line and a complete understanding of this lifeline in,
in scientific terms would obliterate any line you think you have.
Right?
It would just be this cascade of causation and you know,
adding randomness to the picture doesn't help,
right?
It's just,
it's the randomness is just,
you know,
somebody is in your brain rolling dice and all influencing your behavior that
way.
Well,
that's,
that doesn't give you the free will.
People think they have.
So there isn't.
There's A.
Ironically,
there is what seems
on some level deflationary of the,
of the,
the,
the Gravitas of the human spirit for people opens the door to,
at least in my view,
a far more ethical and tolerant and patient and understanding view of,
of,
you know,
human failings and human frailty and,
and just.
And then at that point you can just have a conversation about what's pragmatic,
what works,
what helps people change.
Like in this,
this person over here who's doing terrible things,
is there something we can do to make him a better person?
Well,
if there is less,
do that without all the judgment.
Wouldn't it be amazing if that's how we treated these public shaming events?
Like,
wouldn't,
wouldn't it be amazing if we gave someone an opportunity to say,
this is,
this is what I did,
this is how awful I feel about this.
I would never do that again.
I'm a different person.
That was 20 years ago,
whatever it was,
and,
and have everybody join in.
Hey,
anyone could be you.
Thank you for being honest about who you are now.
Thank you for evolving.
Thank you for expressing yourself in a way that maybe other people who have also
committed really,
I'm just unsavory or just unfortunate
things in the past,
unfortunately acts in the past.
They can feel relieved by the fact that you've grown and evolved to become a
better person and that you're a,
you're a different thing now and you are the product of all of your experiences.
You're not,
you're not this one thing.
You're not stuck in who you were when you were 16 years old.
If you were mark and mark and you hit that guy with a stick,
whatever,
whatever he did,
you didn't.
You're not stuck in that spot for ever.
It's not a scarlet letter.
It's not a mark on your forehead that you keep for life.
Yeah.
But the thing about the Liam Neeson incident,
which I find so interesting is that there's a case where they,
what he's revealing about himself is,
is pretty amazing,
right?
It's like,
it's like he,
he just decided,
okay,
we need a,
a truth and Reconciliation Commission for who I used to be.
Right.
You know,
and,
uh,
just volunteered this.
And for me,
like I like,
you know,
I don't actually understand that state of mind.
I mean there are many abrons states of mind that I can understand.
I certainly understand what it's like to,
to want to harm somebody and uh,
you know,
to feel vengeance and all that.
But the instrumental violence piece,
I don't understand.
I've never felt like,
okay,
this type of person wronged me or someone close to me.
So anytime any person of that type will do right like that.
But that is such a problem,
the world over in human history that it is,
it is just fascinating ethically,
for someone of his stature to reveal that about himself.
And he put it in terms of,
of,
of honor.
I mean,
it was,
it was an honor.
I mean,
this is what,
what is so dysfunctional about honor culture,
right?
This is what,
this is what we see more in the south than anywhere else in the country.
And this is what you see basically everywhere you go in the Middle East.
And this is what Islam inculcates to a degree that's fairly unmatched in,
in its community.
This notion of honor is,
does link up with this tendency to find satisfaction in instrumental violence
like,
but when you,
when you try to run that software on my brain that just looks like madness,
right?
The idea that any other person will do right of a certain type that's just,
you know,
like I,
I don't read that resonates not at all right.
And so,
um,
it's just damn interested in the fact that the lesson being taken from this
seems to be,
this is,
this should be the end of your career for having talked about this in the way.
And again,
I apologize if there's some part of the story that I've gotten wrong or I'm not
missing or missing,
but it seemed to me that he was always counting this in the,
the horror and amazement appropriate to the,
to the disclosure like he can't believe was inhabiting this state of
consciousness.
And you know,
it's just an amazing thing to reveal about yourself.
So yeah,
and I'm sure he regrets every second of it.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's the wrong fucking punchline.
The thing that should happen is
someone with a lot to lose,
should be able to say,
you know,
how ugly a human mind can be.
This is an experience I had,
right?
This is who I was and you know,
how much I have to live for and how much I have to lose.
We have to talk about this kind of mania.
They can get humming on a human brain,
right?
We see this eight.
Every time you open the paper,
you see someone in the grip of this kind of thing.
Right?
It even happened to me,
right?
I think it was an amazing conversation to start.
And the fact that the result is just,
you know,
in an,
an auto defay uh,
is,
is the problem.
We're,
we're trying to fight our way through it.
Isn't it to.
Because there's too many voices.
I mean,
there's just so many people that are reacting to it.
If he's dealing with,
he's not dealing with three or four or five voices.
He's dealing with millions of people to get to chime in on this and get a few
thousand of those people that are furious at you.
You know,
like you were saying like it doesn't.
It doesn't.
That doesn't work.
I was just about to say I was going to make a comparison to your podcast with
Jack,
but you're not listening to them reading the comments,
but he's.
He's getting this gigantic signal from a huge number of people you know.
So this is all over my google news feed.
I saw it on Yahoo.
I saw it in all these different publications are talking about Liam Neeson's
case and so then everybody starts timing in and then the virtue signaling ratio
is very high and the anger ratio is very high than the people that think he's
secretly still racist and doesn't want to admit it is very high.
And then there's also the fact that he's a man of wealth and privilege and he's
successful and famous and there's got to be a bunch of jealousy that's attached
to that and a bunch of people that want to knock him down because he's at a very
high hill.
Yeah.
It was a lot going on there.
And I,
I,
um,
I don't know.
I feel,
I feel for the guy,
again,
I don't know him,
but I just,
I remember,
and again,
forgive me if I get this slightly wrong,
but isn't it true that his wife,
Natasha Richardson just died in this freak accident that she's a skiing
accident?
Fell and hit her head.
But,
but honestly,
she didn't even fall.
She wasn't moving when she fell.
She was standing on a ski slope and fell from a standing position and hit her
head on the,
you know,
the hard snow obviously.
And I mean it's just,
it's all it takes.
Yeah,
it's brutal.
Um,
yeah.
So,
and on top of that,
I believe his cousin or his nephew,
nephew or niece,
died the same way.
Not the same way in terms of fell skiing.
But also hit their head and ride.
Wow.
So it was like Jesus Christ is this guy and obviously there's many people out
there that
are experienced at far greater tragedy.
I'm not trying to quantify it,
but yeah,
he's,
you know,
he,
he tried to talk about a real thing,
you know,
and tried to talk about a real thing.
And,
and he's,
he's given some interviews since then where he's,
you know,
he said,
I'll look,
I'm not a racist,
I'm just telling you I was in such a fucked up state of mind because of this
rate that I was willing to do something irrational and horrible,
but he didn't know,
but he didn't.
Interesting.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
But,
and again,
it will take it full circle people.
These same people who are calling for his head are prepared to forgive other
people who did do that thing.
It's so dependent.
Like I had Mike Tyson on the podcast and one of the things that I got when I
said it was on part of my,
that was fast.
I've asked so many people were like,
fuck that rapist.
Fuck this guy.
Fuck that.
All these different things about him,
what I wanted to get into him with him was who he was when he was 12 years old,
when he was a little boy,
when he met custom motto and was taught out of box and was fucking hypnotized,
and this is one of the really important things that came out of that podcast was
custom model who was not just this boxing legend who took in this young kid from
the ghetto that didn't have a family,
but also hypnotized him.
Tip Man ties them to be a destroyer.
He specifically was saying to him,
you don't exist.
The task exists.
You're going to move forward.
You're going to Bob and weave and rip the body,
and he was programming this kid to get incredible amounts of positive response
from violent acts.
Violent acts in a boxing ring,
and that's where he got his identity.
That's where he got all of his love and so he became this guy and one of the
things that I said to him,
I said,
did anybody ever teach teach you how to turn it off?
And he's like,
no.
Nobody did.
Like,
I'm not.
I'm not Mike Tyson and I was never like that.
I was never like that,
but I was far more violent when I was fighting far more violent,
far more prone to violence.
It was my trigger was very short because I was thinking about it all the
fighting all the time I fought.
I probably had 100 fights.
I was ready to go.
Like your.
Your brain has a.
If you're.
If you're getting kicked in the face and punched in the face a lot and you're
doing it through your developmental period from the time you 50 for me was 15.
From him it was like 12 or 13.
You have a different way of looking at the world because this is also in the
recipes in the recipes are also.
You might get knocked the fuck out.
You might get head kicked,
you might get kicked in the neck with a Shin and you know,
you wake up and your friends are slapped me in the face of putting ice on you.
This is all real and when you have that,
the positive that comes from that.
When you were a 12 year old boy and you're hypnotized by this great man who's
teaching you how to fight and you're getting so much love,
you've never gotten love in your life,
you've never gotten positive feedback and you're getting so much of it from this
and then no one's teaching you how to turn it off and you're wondering why this
guy would he grows up to become a fucking maniac is punching people in the
street.
It's just just crazy and yelling at reporters.
I'll fuck you in the ass white boy.
All that crazy shit that he did.
He was a maniac.
I mean there's no.
No one taught him how to reflect.
There was no Sam Harris App for meditation for Mike Tyson in 1986.
You know,
he was just a maniac.
I mean,
one problem we have here is that we don't have a norm around a good norm around
mental health and we have zero norms around mental training.
Right?
So mean.
So physical training.
Very good analogy between meditation as mental training,
which sounds just like esoteric and woo.
That sounds like new age,
specious nonsense to many people,
but if you roll back the clock 100 years physical training,
which made no sense,
there were no norms around him and the only guy lifting a dumbbell was that guy
with the handlebar mustache and the leopard,
you know,
Bikini or whatever.
He was wearing the freak show,
right?
The singlet.
Yeah.
And now we have a,
we have a total understanding of the norms around physical training.
Like,
uh,
you're,
there's just,
you're actually a freak if you don't do some kind of exercise.
They have even changed and evolved over the last decade or so.
It's gotten far more complicated in nuance.
It's continually evolving,
but the,
the framework that the paradigm,
the fact that there's something to do to get better physically and that,
those,
those changes matter,
they,
you can engage your body intelligently so as to improve it in all across many
different variables.
Flexibility,
strength,
uh,
that's all totally understood.
And now we're just refining the protocol with mental training,
uh,
and specifically the training of attention and how you respond to the uprising
of your own negative emotion,
right?
That is something that has been going on for thousands of years in
contemplative,
mostly eastern context.
And that's something that,
you know,
Buddhism really has a lot of specifically an asymmetric amount of wisdom to,
to,
uh,
share on.
And it's,
um,
yeah,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm very excited to be spending more time on it because it's that the locus of
so much of the fragmentation or in our lives now is the smartphone.
So what's happening,
what the,
what this thing is doing to us is continually amplifying not only our desire for
our approval,
but the ability to react in a like.
So there's just no reason to hesitate to condemn this thing that you're seeing
like this.
This upwelling of negative emotion you see the out of the outrage,
you feel when you see something on twitter,
right?
Is,
it's shortening everybody's views,
right?
It's making road rage more of a kind of a general feature of our,
of our lives.
And um,
this is,
this is all trainable,
like you can actually,
you can actually learn that when you suddenly feel anger in response to
something that seems to have happened in the world,
if you just pay attention to the experience of anger,
he just feel the,
the,
the mirror physiology of it.
And get out of your thoughts about it.
Like you actually,
you notice thought as a process,
you let that go.
You're not continuing to have a conversation with yourself about all the reasons
why you should be angry or you should attack this person and you just become
interested in,
in anger as response.
The half life of the emotion is like seconds,
right?
It's impossible to stay angry for very long.
If you get out of the story you're telling yourself about why you should be
angry.
Now there are certain situations where anger is,
is appropriate and it's good to have access to that energy.
I'm not,
I'm not advocating that everyone just get labatt automized and not react to
anything.
But until you can actually be mindful.
I mean mindfulness is the technical word for what this is.
And until you can actually get out of the,
the thoughts and just pay attention to,
to,
in this case a negative emotion,
you have zero choice.
You're gonna stay angry for as long as you stay angry for and people have this
experience of being angry for days about things or being angry for hours.
There's no way to stay angry for more than moments if,
if,
unless you're just lost in the story.
And um,
it becomes a kind of superpower to,
to be able to say,
do I need to be angry about this?
Or like how useful is it to stay angry about this?
And,
and,
and you can just get off the ride,
right?
You can literally,
like I,
I see a tweet from somebody who's trying to destroy my life and I feel this
initial contraction and I can decide how long I want to feel that way for.
Right?
And that's an amazing thing to be able to do.
And it's based on a kind of training that very few people know even exists and
that.
And so again,
it's like you're like,
I'm now the guy in the,
in the,
the Leopard singlet,
right?
But it's,
um,
you know,
more and more,
uh,
we're,
we're going to understand that this is just has to be part of everybody's
toolkit.
Well,
it would be amazing if they taught kids that in school,
if you have to learn that when you're learning math and history,
people are doing that.
But my wife actually does that really in high school.
Six-Year-Olds.
Whoa.
You can teach,
you can teach mindfulness to.
I mean in the beginning,
what they're learning is just basic awareness of their inner lives are like just
being able to name the emotion they're feeling is an amazing capacity and a six
year old and a six year old is just acting out something and you're now teaching
them to,
to know in that moment that what's pushing them from behind his sadness or anger
or embarrassment or cycling.
Just to be able to have that recursive ability to reflect.
That's already a major gain in,
in,
uh,
kids that age.
But yeah,
you can learn it very early.
I actually,
this was something I was talking about with Stephen Fry on,
on my podcast as Steven was very scared and he,
he's,
he's actually,
he's adorable.
He's starting the blog cast.
I really enjoyed that is just,
you're in the presence of just such a nice guy.
Guys radiates you no decency.
Um,
but uh,
he was,
you know,
fairly skeptical of just like,
why would you ever have to train mindfulness or meditation and I mean,
the analogy that came up came up to me,
he came up for me on the fly there was that it is actually a lot like learning
to read in the sense that none of us remember having the,
having gone through the ordeal of learning to read right now,
that learning to read was a hassle,
right?
Like that did not come easily to most people and he had now is just now you,
if you look at a page of text in a language you understand you can't help but
decode it,
right?
It's just effortless.
And so,
I mean,
this is these kinds of emotional tools and cognitive tools,
just the,
the ability to self regulate emotion in,
by becoming aware of it as a process,
uh,
that is something that I think we could teach kids much earlier and then we
would be in the presence of,
of young adults who would naturally have a facility,
a facility for it that,
where they won't even,
they wouldn't even remember how hard it was to acquire it.
Yeah.
What it was talking about earlier with Mike Tyson and you know,
his,
his coaching and his,
I mean he essentially got mental coaching on how to accomplish one thing,
a mental coaching on how to have the perfect mindset for one thing.
How to,
how to,
how to kick people's ass.
What he didn't have was mental coaching on how to deal with the pressures of
life,
especially live.
I mean,
and almost no one really understands what life is like to be a famous 20 year
old heavyweight champion of the world.
I mean,
there's no one had to be salient.
Yeah.
It's got to be alien.
I mean at the end to ask this kid to manage this state when you know you're
talking about someone who just six years prior was virtually homeless and had no
love in his life at all and was being hypnotized by some madman who a,
you know,
a boxing wizard who lives in the catskills and did what we were talking about
earlier about who you are now versus who you were 20,
30 years ago when you meet Mike Tyson.
Mike Tyson is the sweetest,
nicest,
friendliest guy.
He's so soft spoken.
He's really kind.
He hugs people.
He's a really nice guy,
you know,
and at one point in time he was the scariest motherfucker on the planet earth.
Yeah.
There's actually,
there's another sort of uncanny valley here in,
in martial arts training that I spend a lot of time in when you're training in
martial arts and seeing the world through this lens of violence and potential
violence,
but you're training in a way that's never really putting your skills to the
test.
So you're,
you're basically,
you're as a,
as a young man,
you're living with this fundamental uncertainty as to whether or not you
actually are capable of anything.
So you're training like fake martial arts,
right?
Right.
Or at least martial arts where most of it is it kind of pantomime of violence
and it's not being pressured,
tested.
So it's not like you were,
you're competing and you know what it's like to kick someone in the head and it
actually works,
right?
It's like this is your sparring,
but it's all,
you have to keep everything safe.
Right.
You know,
um,
or even if it's full contact,
you have headgear and you've got this just like you're not.
There's still basic uncertainty about what's going to go down on the street,
if,
you know,
if it's in the presence of real violence and they are your,
especially as a teenager,
you're in this fairly toxic state of like sort of always preparing for violence
that is still is in,
you know,
in most people's lives,
a pretty low order of probability that it's going to occur.
Uh,
and yet it's all,
it's also backed by this fear of,
you know,
you just kind of the ego fear of maybe you're just full of Shit and you're just
here,
you're just gonna get your ass kicked.
If this ever happens.
And with someone like,
you know,
someone who's a real,
obviously someone like Mike Tyson,
there shouldn't,
there shouldn't be any uncertainty about like,
he's got nothing to prove these in a bar.
And somebody says,
you know,
what are you looking at?
At minimum he doesn't have this fear of like if he,
if he walks away from that challenge,
he knows he's walking away,
not because he was scared,
maybe he,
he's going to lose a fistfight with this guy,
right?
He's the best boxer on earth at that moment.
It's,
it's that he's,
he's,
he's got way more to lose than the other guy.
Like I felt like,
why does he want to be rolling around in the parking lot with some stranger,
you know.
So,
um,
it's a.
So there's this,
this is a very unhappy place that a lot of martial artists are in,
which is,
you know,
they don't actually know what they are capable of and they're living all the
time with this,
this,
you know,
just kind of training software running in their heads and it's,
it's,
um,
it's a weird space to be in.
Well,
it's one of the things that's so great about Brazilian Jujitsu.
Exactly.
The Brazilian Jiu Jitsu.
You mean you're not getting punched and you're not getting kicked,
but you are absolutely going full blast and you have 100 percent confidence when
she reached a certain level that you could do that to an untrained person within
his frame.
You are pressure testing it,
you know that it works now.
You don't know.
I would argue there people still lose sight of the fact that in reality people,
people are punching and they're not training a lot of punching or defense.
And then there are weapons and then there's the guy's friend who can come up and
start kicking you in your head.
Just so you know,
like,
like how good an idea was it to pull guard when you know someone else can walk
up.
Uh,
but you know.
Yeah.
It's within,
it's within its purview.
Yeah.
You're not the,
you're,
you're working out all of your illusions and that's,
that's,
that's one reason why so many of us find it addictive.
Sure.
Yeah.
There's that.
And there's also the so nice Jujitsu people are so friendly and I think that's
one of the reasons why they're so friendly.
They're not carrying around all that bullshit that a lot of people carry around,
including,
you know,
there's some grown men that have never been in a fight in their life and they
get a couple of beers in them and they start talking crazy shit came in.
You don't even know how to fight.
You don't.
What do you see?
Someone who wants to jump into a nascar race.
He never driven a car,
like stop talking to some guy with cauliflower ear.
Even know what that means.
Right?
Yeah.
It's,
I mean,
to be a human being is complicated,
to be a man and in the face of altercations with other men is uniquely
complicated.
You know,
the kind of altercations that men get into the kind of bravado and chest puffing
and shit talking and the consequences of those things.
Like you were talking about Liam Neeson,
his wife falling down and hitting her head.
A friend of mine was working in a bar and in Long Island and one of the bouncers
got in a fight with some guy and punched the guy,
knocked him out.
The guy fell back,
hit his head off the curb and died,
and that happens all the time.
When people get knocked out,
they hit their head on the ground.
They die.
Yeah,
yeah.
I actually,
I did when I,
before I had a podcast,
I was getting my midlife crisis,
took the form of beginning really back into martial arts again for after a
hiatus of maybe 25 years.
I had a,
a lawyer who,
who focused on kind of self defense law.
I mean,
he was constantly dealing with cases where someone is either either claiming
self defense or legit self defense claim,
but they're basically screwed.
I mean they,
like they punch someone and that person fell down on the hit a fire hydrant and
died,
right?
So they're,
they're trying to beat a murder rap,
you know?
And so I just had him in a blog post,
had him walk me and I had a bunch of.
I had two people comment,
ask questions as well.
I had um,
Matt Thornton,
who's um,
uh,
John Cavanaugh's,
Jujitsu coach.
I'm a ask questions in this blog post and I had rory Miller who's a self defense
trainer and just just to try to flesh out all of the things you should be
thinking about when you're the kind of person who
use at all preparing for the possible eventuality of violence because people who
trained with guns or own own guns or carry knives or do martial arts don't
actually understand what happens when,
you know,
like they,
they agreed to fight somebody or they like,
like,
like in,
unless you,
unless you're emo is,
and this should be your emo to avoid violence at all.
Virtually any cost,
right?
Like you're always just trying to leave the premises.
If there's some sort of challenge that could become,
if that's not your,
your emo,
you're just wandering into potential situations where you can find yourself in
court for having shoved a guy and he,
you know,
fell into the street and got run over,
right?
You're like.
And then now you're the guy who's looking at the prospect of going to prison
for,
you know,
for a murder or,
or,
um,
you know,
second degree murder.
And so anyway,
I had him walk me through all of the INS and outs of all of that.
It was a fascinating conversation because yeah,
there are people who,
you know,
I mean there are extreme cases,
there are women who have shot,
they're totally crazy husband who's like waving a baseball bat at their heads
and they're in prison for years for this,
you know,
just real miscarriages of justice where like the like you would think that the,
the,
you know,
it would be very easy to prove that she was in fear for her life in this case.
And this was a legitimate use of lethal force.
It's just so hard with no one's there.
Yeah.
If no one's there.
I mean if you have eyewitnesses or if it's a public thing that happens and
there's video of it,
but you know,
someone does something to someone and no one's around and you punch someone and
they get knocked out and they die.
And he said,
no,
this guy was threatening to kill me.
He was chasing me.
He was threatening to kill me.
I was terrified for my life.
He lunged towards me.
I saw the opening,
I took it,
and now he's dead.
You can go to jail forever.
I mean that's that.
That's a reality.
I mean,
you should absolutely without a doubt avoid violence at all costs,
but you should also know how to fight.
I definitely think that's very important.
It's very important,
but very few people trained.
So it's like in the curriculum of,
of learning how to fight training in,
in whatever martial art or arts.
There's in most cases,
very little time spent training avoidance.
Yes.
Right.
And that's,
that's,
that's a real missing piece because that is the most important thing to train.
I mean it's like,
you know,
especially if you have real skills,
right?
Especially if you're walking around armed,
I mean that,
that was the one,
the one in interesting psychological corrective that concealed carry does for
many people is that once you're squawking around with a gun,
you realize what the problem of,
of what,
what any altercation can become.
Like A,
you're not going to get into a shoving match with somebody if you're wearing a
gun in your belt because you like it.
If that escalates,
you're pulling out your gun and then as a decision of whether to kill somebody
know,
so you know,
and you know,
I don't have a ton of experience in this area,
but you know,
for all the firearm training I've done with people,
um,
I just get,
you know,
I,
I know like former swat operators who are just out there constantly armed and
these are like the last guys who are going to get involved in anything.
I mean they used to be cops,
but now they don't even feel any burden to police any.
Like it's like they're just,
they're retired,
emphatically retired,
right?
Um,
because they just recognize how haywire anything can go for them.
If,
if,
uh,
you know,
any,
any process of conflict gets started.
And again,
I think this goes back to understanding how to manage your mind.
You know,
when the shit hits the fan and things go crazy,
it's,
it's very difficult for people to maintain a rational state of mind and things
can escalate so quickly.
Things can turn to violence so quickly,
especially with irrational people or untrained people or people that aren't
aware of consequences or maybe can't process it well by and the crucial piece
which you know,
many
seasoned fighters and,
and you know,
professionals don't have area I would think many don't have is this sort of
this,
this valley where your ego concerns are not worked out.
It's like when you,
when you,
when you feel the emotional burden of a loss of face,
right?
So like if Jocko willink is in a bar and someone says something nasty to him or
to his wife,
Jocko doesn't have anything to prove.
Like Jocko knows he's a bad ass,
right?
So jocko knows that he just,
it's time to get out of the bar because he doesn't want to deal with the
psychopath who doesn't know who he's dealing with.
A by someone who's not trained like Jocko.
Right?
Could feel that backing down,
especially back in down in front of your wife or your girlfriend.
That is such an ego blow that the temptation to get into this,
this monkey dance with the other person is just,
is a.
it's impossible to recover from the very dangerous game.
Yeah.
And people get into it all the time and I've seen so many people get into it
that just don't.
They don't have any cards.
Literally bluffing a God damn it,
man,
to stop doing this.
You know,
look,
I've been doing martial arts my whole life and I'm terrified of fights.
I see.
Fides is like,
get the fuck out of here before this goes bad when it goes sideways,
you know,
men are just,
we have thousands of years of awful DNA,
you know,
we really do.
We were violent.
Hundreds of thousands.
Millions.
Violence was imperative.
It was imperative for survival.
You had,
he had to be able to react and react quickly and yet you had to know what to do
with your genes are never gonna.
Make it to the next stage,
which is,
this is a controversial thing to say.
And I got in trouble,
or one of my podcast guests,
Gavin de Becker,
uh,
the security,
a guru got in trouble in my podcast talking about the primacy of,
of intuition here.
Like,
our intuitions are actually really good for detecting something that makes us
uncomfortable about another person.
Right?
And this is,
this becomes politically incorrect really fast,
right?
Because it's like,
you know,
if you see a guy on an elevator who makes you uncomfortable,
Gavin's advice,
and I think,
I think the real sane advice is just don't get on,
but there are many people who get on just because they want to prove they're not
racist,
right?
Or they're not.
It's psych.
And,
and uh,
I actually know someone who was in a situation like that and it didn't work out
well.
And so intuition is bad for so many things.
We have terrible intuitions for statistics and probability theory,
and it's like word over reliant.
We,
you know,
whole careers and Nobel prizes have been won on,
people like Danny Conoman have have shown us how.
It's not only that our intuitions are bad for,
for these judgments,
but the reliably bad,
and we can understand there's this,
there's a structure to how bad they are.
But for judging people who are dangerous,
who gives us the,
who makes,
who makes the hair stand up on the back of our neck for reasons we can't
understand,
um,
you know,
for where the eye contact was wrong or though,
or just the way they were just like a,
what's called a witness check,
you know,
like someone comes up to you and engages you and then they look to,
they just kind of look to check for witnesses right now.
Like people don't,
aren't aware that that's even a thing,
right?
But when like that body language is very salient to us.
And,
and uh,
there,
there are hundreds of things like that that,
that,
um,
we immediately feel that prompt,
you know,
an intuitive response.
And these are intuitions that are from a self defense point of view are worth
listening to because it's like the worst case scenario is you wind up being a
little rude.
They're like,
sorry,
I'm not,
you know,
I can't talk,
but I'm a.
people are,
you know,
people are very dogmatically being kind of trained to ignore those,
those kinds of intuitions.
And what do you think those intuitions are like?
What do you think intuitions are?
But when you meet someone,
you go,
Whoa,
this person feels dangerous.
Like,
what is that?
What's happening?
Well,
there's a lot of it,
you know,
gays detection is a big one.
I mean,
we know what people do with their eyes is a,
is a,
is a major variable in just how we feel that,
you know,
the,
the relationship is going.
Um,
but it's a.
and there's their micro expressions that we notice in people that were not aware
of noticing,
you know,
but like there's just,
there's,
this is,
this is not well understood.
Uh,
and we're bad judges of whether someone is telling the truth.
I mean,
this,
this has been fairly well studied.
I mean there are people who,
even people who work for the FBI or not,
you know,
much better than chance and detecting whether somebody is lying.
But that's just,
we get so much information by,
you know,
body language and being somebody's presence and we get it so fast that it's,
um,
again,
I mean there,
whether we understand it or not,
they're evolutionary reasons why this is so.
I mean,
if,
if we've evolved for anything as social primates,
we have evolved to detect stuff that just is a precursor to violent intent in,
in others.
Do you think it's just gaze or do you think you can send the energy of someone?
There's certain movements that people make when they're thinking about hitting
him.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's certain like there's like a twitchiness to them.
I got while pulled back like almost like a spring or a bow.
There's like a feeling you get around people that are looking to hit people.
Yeah.
Well there's again,
all of that still vision,
but there's,
you know,
I mean who,
who knows where to texting pheromones where we could be detecting people's level
of stress.
I mean just how to end up there.
But,
and this goes beyond,
this is beyond just physical violence.
This is just,
you know,
detecting psychopaths who are being manipulated.
I mean,
just detecting mean there,
there are ways to spot people line,
uh,
you know,
I mean just,
they're,
they're tells like too much information,
you know,
like people who are giving you support the superfluous information,
uh,
as,
as an overcorrection because they're anticipating that you're going to doubt
their story and so they're filling in blanks that you don't even need filled in.
Right.
And,
and it's the sort of patterns to,
to sort of to that.
But again,
we,
we pick up on a lot of this stuff without consciously being aware of what's
going on.
We just know that that's not a person I want to spend anymore time with.
Right?
Uh,
but you know,
there may be more of a literature on this than I know about,
but a lot of this is not well understood and people like Paul Ekman have done a
lot of stuff on micro micro expressions that goes back probably 30 years at this
point.
And there are people who are outliers who are great at detecting micro
expressions where they really,
they really just understand what's going on,
but it's not.
And,
and ai eventually will be if it is not there already,
we'll be much better than we are doing this.
I'm so scared of that service here that I'm getting that wrong.
Micro expressions are funny because they remind me of microaggressions,
which is one of the,
you know,
one of the weirder social justice warrior things like things that used to be
just slights where someone was just like slightly rude.
Not,
not even slice,
just like,
where do you come from?
Right.
Speaking with an accent.
Where are you from?
Where are your parents from?
Dare you?
How dare you question my authenticity?
Yeah,
no aggression.
It's weird that that's actually accepted,
that this is something that they're actually pushing in certain schools that
microaggressions are a real,
a real thing.
I'm Christina Hoff summers just wrote something about,
uh,
or she,
she put something on her twitter today about a Yale article that was written
today that was put out today about documenting politically incorrect behavior.
So that someday in the future when someone is running for Congress or is up for
Supreme Court or something that you could go back to their college days.
And remember when they said something and I mean one of the examples is woman
uses in this post was compared to a woman to a large animal,
a woman's body to large animal in a private text message that she should have.
Oh,
I should have.
I should've and calls this guy in this,
this article white boy,
this white boy does this.
And the white boy with a saccharin smile does that.
It's like,
which is like overtly racist.
Like they'll just the expression like in the way she's describing it like a
disease,
if this evil character slowly makes his way to run the world and he's been
engineered since the time he was in college.
Well that's going to happen just by,
just based on just based on everyone's use of the tools.
Like you know,
people are not diligently scrubbing their,
their digital history and there may in fact be no way to actually do it.
Right.
And so they're just,
they're trailing the,
they're not even aware of what they're trailing in social media,
so,
so I mean maybe maybe that is,
that will just be a cure for the problem because at a certain point we'll be
dealing with people who were basically born.
They were born on facebook,
right?
Like they don't even have a moment.
Like they've got their baby picture there and everything that followed and
then it'll just seem completely untenable.
Like choose people who've everything.
Yeah.
Just everyone's guilty.
Everyone has said that dumb thing matter of taken the worst possible way.
And if they're going to be hung from that then you know,
no,
no one will survive.
Well it seems like that's what we're dealing with right now in a lot of cases.
You know,
the,
what I think is really important that what you were saying earlier was that
there has to be some sort of path to redeeming themselves that there,
there has to be some accepted way that someone can go about redeeming themselves
and we can allow them to reenter society without constantly bringing it up or
judging them by it.
Or always a attributing their past behavior to who they are right now.
I mean,
look at,
they should be so simple.
But look at my collaboration with Majid Nawaz,
right?
So like we were on this podcast together.
Majid was scheming to form a global caliphate.
I mean the,
the,
the organization,
he was part of him.
He wasn't a jihadist thankfully,
and he wasn't actually blowing people up,
but he was trying to get nuclear weapons in,
in Pakistan into the hands of the worst possible theocrats right?
This was his,
with all of his charisma and all of his energy.
And it's like a mantra.
It is fantastic.
And he used to eight utterly nefarious purpose in my world,
right?
You know,
if you know how much that is an issue for me,
it's like Majid Majid,
nih,
or are just buddies now,
right?
So all I need is a clear path that he took out of the darkness to understand why
he's a valid collaborator.
Now.
And actually on that point,
I,
I've got people breathing down my neck to tell you that we're telling your
audience,
this is how powerful you are,
Joe Rogan.
That the documentary is coming out on the collaboration and it's,
it's out now,
and so it can be found out,
there is what's called Islam in the future of tolerance.
Nice.
And it's actually,
it's not bad.
It actually captures the spirit of our collaboration very well.
Uh,
and you know,
see it if only to recognize how awesome modular because modular is just a
superstar and the scariest thing about the state of public opinion in the Muslim
world from my point of view is just how,
how hard a job he has to just to have a conversation in that community.
I mean it's just,
you know,
he's so marginalized and he's so reasonable,
you know.
But let me take,
come back to that original point.
Here's someone who was,
whose life was purposed toward what,
what I view as one of the most toxic projects I can think of.
Right.
You know,
give the nuclear weapons to the people who want to die as martyrs.
Right.
That's the project,
right?
And Majid has just absolutely awesome collaborator now.
Right?
So there's like we have to,
there has to be a path through some sane conversation to a reboot the wheel.
The worry though for a lot of folks is that you are not really being honest
about you,
who you are currently.
You just want an excuse for,
for,
to be relieved.
It's so clear in some of these cases,
like it's clear me,
take him in the norm.
Mcdonald case is just utterly clear.
Right?
Um,
and I'm,
even though it may in Megan Kelly's case,
utterly clear,
like I don't think unless she's got some white supremacist side Gig that I,
I'm not aware of.
She's just like,
listened,
I'm clueless.
I said,
you know,
I didn't realize.
Well they were looking for an excuse to get rid of her honestly.
But I think that even if they weren't,
I think that still very likely would have been the end.
I mean it's like even if her show had had better ratings,
still that could have been an unrecoverable error.
What if she was black when it doesn't work the other direction?
They reverted back and she said,
what's so bad about blackface?
Well that she could stay on the air.
That's interesting.
I don't know.
I mean it certainly would've been easier.
Yeah.
What have overstaying.
Who Cares?
You want to pretend to be Diana Ross because that was the,
the,
the thing was pretending to be Diana Ross for Halloween,
right?
Yeah.
You want to be Diana Ross,
who was I?
I mean I got to think they could get away with it,
but it's.
I mean it was interesting the,
the thing that happened with Louis ck and Ricky Gervais' and Jerry Seinfeld and
Chris Rock,
that was.
Because I remember when that aired,
I think it was 2011 and I remember there was nothing around that.
It was just,
it was totally fine.
Yeah,
right.
They were using the n word.
I mean the problem,
the thing that was kind of dishonest about the,
the,
the re scandalizing of it was that in the context of that conversation,
it was framed by
the fact that they,
they really were ref referencing one of the more famous pieces of comedy and in
history and they read,
they were referencing Chris Rock's act using the n word.
They're the black people and then their ends and you Louis Rnn,
right.
Like,
like,
you're the only white guy I know who.
And then they're.
So they're talking to in that context and anyway.
Yeah,
it was,
it was interesting how that almost,
I mean that blew back against ricky and one of those things where they're just
looking for more things to be mad at Louis for.
Yeah.
But I mean,
but ricky was also,
I think Chris Rock was a lot of shit.
Yeah.
He took a lot of shit for that because he didn't.
There was no blowback.
Yeah.
Interesting Times.
Yes.
That's probably a good way to end it.
Did three hours.
Yeah,
it is.
It is interesting times.
I mean,
it's probably the most interesting times of our lives in good ways and bad ways.
Yeah.
Well we're,
um,
we're on the front lines of something,
you know,
I,
I don't know if you get enough credit for this,
but you have like,
you pushed out into the space that no one even knew existed.
And Emma,
you're like,
I honestly didn't even know what a podcast was when I learned what a podcast was
when I got invited.
Get interviewed on your podcast the first time,
you know,
so it's like,
it's awesome what,
what you've created here.
So thank you.
It's all,
it's an accident.
I just stuck with it,
stumbled upon it,
and kept going.
Well,
I'm good at that.
Keep it up.
Thank you.
You too.
Excellent.
Sam Harris,
ladies and gentlemen.
Right.
Awesome.
Okay.